61 antifa activists or whatever you want
to call them have been indicted on Rico
charges out of Georgia and this is on
top of the 20 or so that have already
been charged with domestic terrorism for
the actions they took at stop cop city
which includes firebombing and throwing
bricks and other objects as well as you
know there was a shootout and there was
a bunch of violence and destruction that
happened all around the area in Atlanta
outside of Atlanta where they burned
down houses flipped over vehicles and
destroyed them really interesting these
charges dropped today when we're getting
news that Enrique tario received 22
years in prison he was sentenced despite
not actually being at January 6 why did
he get 22 years in prison because he
texted other proud boys cheering them on
during January 6 and uh that's it ladies
and gentlemen there's a lot of news
today and trying to figure out which one
is the one to go it's really tough you
you got Jill Biden's got Co Joe Biden
saying he's going to start wearing a
mask again fouchi is saying he'll be
really upset if nobody wears masks and
they recommend it you've got Tucker
Carlson dropping a trailer for an
interview with the guy who claims that
he was having adult relations with
Barack
Obama man Elon Musk is suing the
Anti-Defamation or threatening to sue
the Anti-Defamation League and then of
course Russian Uh Russian TV
personalities have threatened to Nuke
the United States in retaliation if the
US engages in war with Russia oh boy
talk about a fun day before we get
started however my friends head over to
timcast.net
to our live event October 6th in Miami
if you would like to see me and Luke
rowski host a show with Patrick Bet
David Donald Trump Jr and Matt Gates
it's going to be a lot of fun there's
going to be a pre-show there's going to
be an after show Q&A with all of you in
the audience we've got some uh uh swag
to give out and uh we're even going to
be selling cast Brew Coffee pick up your
tickets now it's going to be Friday
October 6th from from 6:00 to 10:30 p.m.
probably a little bit later and for the
elite members at
timcast.net
hangout session earlier in the day
around 3 p.m. location to be disclosed
to our members exclusively in our
Discord by uh also don't forget to
become a member as a member at the $10
month level you get access to our
uncensored members only shows we have
those up for you at about 10: p.m. every
single night and if you're M for at
least 6 months or you sign up for at
least 25 bucks a month you can submit
questions call into the show and talk to
us and our guests so please do that
click join us to support our work
directly and with your membership we're
going to do a bunch of crazy cool things
we're going to be building a skate park
we're building a coffee shop we're
launching a skate company a skate show
we're launching a poker show we are
trying to heavily influence Culture by
just encouraging people who have skills
and talents in these areas and uh
pushing back on the woke machine so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more is Jackson Hinkle thank
you so much for having me on who are you
what do you do uh I have a YouTube show
it's called the dive with Jackson hle
and I cover geopolitics Russia Ukraine
Africa China anything US foreign
relations and also some of the subjects
we're going to be talking about tonight
right on should be interesting
considering we have that story going
around about that personality saying uh
they're going to they're going to Nuke
the United States I think it's BS but of
course you know we'll get into it and
we'll break that down so should be fun
thanks for hanging out thank you we got
Hannah Clair hanging out hey I'm Hannah
Clair brimo I'm a writer for timcast.net
and you should read it all the time Ian
here too hi everyone actor musician
writer Ian crossin happy to be here at
Ian Crossland hit me up on the internet
but let's get rolling what's up Ken
hello everybody I'm filling in for Serge
he's under the weather today but I'm
here pushing buttons uh let's get
started we got this story from the
Associated Press 61 indicted in Georgia
on racketeering charges connected to
stop cop City movement I love this stuff
they say 61 people have been indicted in
Georgia on racketeering charges in the
sweeping indictment released Tuesday
Republican attorney general Chris Carr
interesting interesting name alleged the
defendants are militant anarchists who
supported a violent movement that
prosecutors traced to the widespread
2020 racial Justice protest the August
29 indictment is the latest application
of the state's anti-racketeering law
also known as a RICO law that comes just
after fton County prosecutor used the
statute to charge former president
Donald Trump and 18 other defendants
the stop cop City effort has gone on for
more than 2 years and at times veered
into vandalism and violence opponents
fear the training center will lead to
Greater milit militarization of the
police and that its construction in an
urban Forest will exacerbate
environmental damage in the poor
majority black area I love that
qualifier that defense of these far-left
extremists let me just pull up that
their Wikipedia entry on stop cop City
and they say domestic Terror charges 20
people in all were hit with these
charges going back to January and
December member on March 6 it was
reported 23 people had thrown large
rocks bricks Molotov cocktails and
through fireworks at police as well of
having set buildings and equipment on
fire had been charged with domestic
terrorism only two of them were from
Atlanta one was from France and one R
from Canada but thank you AP for adding
that needless caveat or not caveat but
qualifier that they're worried it will
it will make environmental damage worse
in this poor majority black area this is
the issue when it comes to the left when
it comes to the right even when you get
serious criminal charges now 81 it
appears the media will do everything to
protect them take a look at this from
NPR domestic terrorism charges in
Georgia are prompting concern over
political repression and they start the
story by saying when Luke Harper went to
Atlanta in early March he thought he
would be staying the weekend a
27-year-old copywriter for Florida was
just going to go there and to join
demonstration in opposition to the
police but on a second night after
attending a music festival with other
protesters he was arrested and accused
of being a domestic terrorist maybe it
was like I don't know when that dude
opened fire on police I think more than
one and the cops shot back and one of
them died or when they went around
burning buildings but this is what you
get right now the other big news which
we'll get into in a second is Enrique
too who is not even at January 6 has
been sentenced to 22 years in prison and
what do you think the media is saying
about
him well they're definitely going to
call him a domestic terrorists I mean
the the contrast between the treatment
between of these two groups or two types
of people is insane
uh it's impossible not to see it as uh
inflammatory and an attempt to try and
push differences I mean yes the AP has
an article about this but it's not being
picked up the same way so few people
know about what's going on in Georgia I
mean I honestly think Tim you're one of
the people who talk about it the most
and that's crazy because it's a
year-long essentially uh Sittin protest
that's all that has repeatedly come to
Violence January 6 while complicated and
obviously made a national impression was
one day and did not cause nearly the
destruction that this is happening to to
fton County so I just don't understand
it it's interesting I think you know a
lot of people are celebrating the
indictment but this came from uh I I
think this indictment is coming from the
state level not from the local level and
it's unsurprising that you know the
Atlanta area which is left leaning
Democrat isn't doing anything for the
most part and it's the state level
government but I'm curious I don't know
exactly where this goes I will say I am
surprised and shocked that charges came
about but then again Georgia is a
weirdly I don't I don't how do you
describe it it's it it's it's a red
state right kind of it's red but it has
a uh several major Democratic
strongholds and it's uh it's a more
interesting and like demographically
complicated State than a lot of red
states which are like you know majority
white or something like that uh it
really is it makes sense that it's a
Battleground State because it's it's in
conflict with itself as much as it is
with many other parts of the US it's I
think it's always good to just take it
back to the point like these people are
going to get maybe a few years behind
bars if that you know uh it's a slap on
the wrist and they're literally
committing domestic terrorism they're
treasonist maybe even and look at that
they get a few years but they're trying
to lock up Julian Assange for the rest
of his life what they're Julian Assange
thing is an assassination yeah right
yeah and with this antifa thing they've
not even been sentenced these are
charges don't be surprised if like in DC
on it was the January 20th 2017 protests
yes they criminally charged 200 some on
people with conspiracy and it was a big
oh oh heavens and then what happened
they all got acquitted charges were
dropped and then they were paid millions
of dollars in a lawsuit so we're seeing
this now but at the same time the
inverse story is about people who are
being raided this this is the crazy
thing they're starting to raid more
people over January 6 they were waiting
for an election year so yeah and then
you know to your point Julian Assange oh
boy
yeah look Julian Assange is a real
threat to the established order Julian
Assange did everything appropriately and
as unless any information has been kept
secret I can only see him doing
journalistic activities and that is
really damaging so what do they do oh
they lock him up and they they they
essentially try to let's just say they
silenced him right what these these
lunatics are doing in Atlanta is just
chaos they've killed people they they've
killed people I mean this they in
Atlanta they killed people you said
they've shot they've uh they shot a cop
the cop didn't die okay well they've
shot more bullets at Americans than
Putin's Army has we'll leave it at that
all right fair point I mean that's true
but you well hold on hold on actually
there are Americans on the ground
fighting in Ukraine so they are getting
shot at by Putin's forces but they're
not like I guess declared us they're not
there doing official business of the US
yeah I don't I don't think that matters
to be honest like like the US
intentionally has people there is
intentionally engaging in this conflict
what do you mean they're not in war with
Ukraine we're just sending them tons of
money and Military Support yeah and
intelligence and volunteers and weapons
for those volunteers and training for
those volunteers well we love service in
this country we think it's great to help
other people uh I I think the antifa
story is so interesting
because this is sort of the heaviest hit
that I've seen to antifa I mean Portland
cannot get their situation under control
and in contrast it's the same day that
we see the longest sentence handed down
to anyone involved in anything related
to January 6 I mean if you can't see
that the justice system has favorites I
don't know what we will'll tell you uh I
don't I don't know how people can have
faith in any sort of uh judicial branch
if state or what or anything I mean the
federal government is sending thousands
of people they they've charged thousands
of people I think it's th6 the last doj
number I saw uh in connection to January
6 uh 600 people at least have been
sentenced and in contrast you know
Justin Jes Jones who's a state
representative in uh Tennessee got
reinstated after he led a you know
protest on the floor of the chamber that
disrupted official official proceedings
I assume that's also a form of Sous
conspiracy but Tennessee has not gone
after him for that I mean well it it
just shows that like there are some
things that we are willing to let slip
by depending on what you're promoting I
I do want to give a shout out to
Christopher Carr of Georgia because it's
funny because you our is named Chris car
he was absent last week he was on
vacation wonder what he was up to yeah
maybe he's actually Moonlighting as the
Georgia attorney general no but we often
talk about how it's like we we see not a
single Republican or conservative do
anything as the left runs rampant
firebombing well he is he is shout out
now I mean B minus C+ right it's good
that these Psychopaths who are
firebombing buildings burning them down
flipping over Vehicles shooting at cops
it's good they're being criminally
charged and he's going after them with
some like he's he's going after these
Rico good they conspire they plan these
things there's the crazy video of like
100 plus people I hope he gets all of
them and arrests all of them there is a
difference however I I don't I don't
much care for like tit for tet in the
sense that you know in Georgia they
indict Donald Trump the front runner for
the Republican party and then you get a
guy saying oh yeah I'm going to arrest
some extremists who are at this this cop
thing I'm like those are totally
different territories I'm still glad
that it's happening it's not exactly
what every everyone is asking for when
it comes to corruption you've got
Democrats who have complained about the
election who lobbied election officials
who begged people to vote for for
somebody else who claimed Trump was a
Russian spy that's seditious conspiracy
when you have Hillary Clinton prod you
know uh effectively I correct me I'm
wrong but funding the steel dossier
resulting in a fine and a bunch of other
things I mean that's seditious
conspiracy accusing the president of
being a spy to try and win an election
that is stealing power trying to I guess
the only argument is Trump wasn't in
office at the time and uh and Joe Biden
was but the problem is we see all of
that and there's no action being taken
against any of the Democrats who are in
office who are pushing the
stuff yeah it seems crazy one step at a
time I suppose the I I'm with you I'm
glad that these violent protesters are
facing Justice um but I am concerned
yeah you could call it that a violent
protest Riot these people that were
shooting cops yeah for sure and uh but
what concerns me a little bit is that
it's uh I think you mentioned Tit for
Tat that the bar is getting raised like
okay now we've decided it's okay to
charge someone with 80 counts of this
now we're going to go someone over there
okay because like you said earlier
there's the left the right and the
establishment The Establishment don't
care what side of the culture War you're
on it will use that side's justification
to go after that side and then that
side's justification to go back after
that side and then happily stay on top
of the hill so I don't like this this
escalation of lawfare but it you know
the guys that are shooting at cops they
need to go it is law fair but the last
thing I'll say is like you said the
people that have committed all these war
crimes in Syria or in wherever you know
they're they're never going to be held
accountable those are The Untouchables
I'm pretty sure Obama won an award
called the Peace Prize yeah and you know
he blew up kids Air striking uh you know
wedding processions all that stuff yeah
here's here's an important piece of the
AP news that y'all are going to love
they say among those charged domestic
terrorism in March near the Music
Festival and indicted last week as
Thomas Jurgens the Southern Poverty Law
Center staff attorney Jurgens lawyers
said his client wore a bright green hat
a well-known identifier used by legal
observers and his arrest alarmed many
human rights organizations the Law
Center called an example of heavy-handed
law enforcement intervention against
protesters dcal County district attorney
Sher Boston a Democrat mentioned her
concerns about jurgen's prosecution in
announcing her June decision to withdraw
from criminal cases connected to the
movement listen my friends
just explain to me where you think this
country is currently at when a when the
Democrat district attorney outright says
they are not going to prosecute or or be
involved in criminal cases against
terrorists and Falton county is trying
to indict the front runner for the for
their rival political party and his
lawyers just call it whatever you want I
don't care literally don't but uh yo
something crazy is going on something
absolutely insane is happening when you
have 81 people being charged on either
conspiracy or domestic Terror by a
Republican and a Democrat being like I'm
not going to be involved in any of those
criminal charges like these people shot
at cops MH and then they're like the
January Sixers should be rounded up and
raro gets 22 years in prison dude wasn't
even there wasn't even there well the
majority of the of the people arrested
are out of state in Georgia for stop cop
city right so Georgia's literally under
attack from people who are not from
Georgia and their attorney general is
like no it's fine I'm I'm not interested
in taking part what is this domestic
they call it domestic terrorism but if a
guy from France comes to the United
States and commits a ter Act of
terrorism that's not domestic ter Dom
means that they are Americans attacking
America this than there's a french guy
and a Canadian guy yeah apparently so
it's just straight up International
terrorism guys came to the United States
to wreak havoc on cops that's that's
interal terrorism if this was happening
in like in in Hungary or some other
country you know they'd be sending in
Victoria Newan to go and like launch a
coup and install a new government I we
we're literally living in a banana
Republic right now it's insane I used to
shop at a store called The Banana
Republic it was like they were softening
me I never why they named that store
that it's like it's sells like I think I
got my first suit they were making it
cool it's like it's it's owned by the
same company that owns like Gap that's
their name well then when someone says
something like you ever hear of banana
the ban you know Banana Republic is they
like yeah for sure and then their mind
they're thinking of like a shopping mall
banana and they're like I remember that
story theyve been conditioning us years
Banana Republic right now is that crazy
that we named one of our corporate
capitalist well we didn't the yeah this
this this fascist thing banana they
named it the Banana Republic like after
the countries that we were ripping off
so uh let's jump to this story around
the same time that we were learning that
several antifa far-left extremists were
being eded on Rico charges we also got
this news proud boys leader Enrique Taro
ex proud boys leader sentenced to 22
years for January 6 Riot role and that
role was he was texting people cheering
them
on that's it this is freaky man look if
you want to argue someone incited
someone else to violence like what do
you get for that a couple years if that
depending on the ex the seriousness or
nature of the crime Charles Manson for
instance got life for inciting those
guys to go f it up I mean telling people
to go murder somebody he say he just
said go f it up and they took that to
mean okay so they went and then they
ended up killing these people and
they're like nope Manson incited it
Manson's going away I don't I don't
trust any of these charges and riario
was not there this is is insane here's
the story they say he's uh been sent to
22 years for his in prison for his role
in January 6 he was one of six proud boy
leaders to be charged for conspiring to
stop the certification of the 2020
election taro's originally scheduled
hearing was postponed blah blah blah
they wanted 33 years he got 22 uh let's
uh I want to they highlight a few things
and also they gave a whole bunch of
other dudes 15 to 20
years bigs got uh 17 Taro was convicted
for obstructing an official proceeding
conspiracy to prev an officer from
discharging their duties obstruction of
law enforcement during a civil disorder
and destruction of government property
to the value over a thousand toio wasn't
at the actual Capital Riot because he
had been arrested days earlier and he'd
been told to leave the city so he did
apparently he went to DC instead
prosecutors say from a hotel outside of
DC Taro directed his proud boys to
attack the capital without him taro's
attorneys have said he wasn't in contact
with any members of the organization
during the riot and pointed to nordian
and bigs as being the orchestrators of
the riot further they said participating
in a plan for the proud boys to protest
on January 6 is not the same as
directing others on the ground to storm
the capital by any means necessary and
that's the issue apparently that's it he
wasn't there there was no actual plan
among any of The Proud boys to do
anything they were unarmed many of them
just did dumb things and if you Riot
yeah you write especially at the capital
during the electoral vote count I think
you you're you're you get some serious
charges but like what a year 16 months
maybe for knocking down barricades or
smashing windows I do think it is fair
to say it is personally offensive to
smash the windows of our capital
building you know man I I Look to
American history and all the stuff I
reject and and despise the corruption
but it is amazing to go to DC and see
all the all the art and all the history
and people smashing stuff and bashing
windows and trying to break their way in
really really bad I say criminal charges
and we'll be we'll be really harsh
really let's let's be really really
harsh a rider who does this should get
18 months oh and they've already served
that that's time served they've already
been there go you you look at these guys
who uh this guy burned down a police
station in Minneapolis he it's four
years mhm you look at some of the what
is it the malov cocktail uh lawyers what
do they get a year I think 22 years
they're ending they're they're
effectively ending these dudes lives
yeah I mean that's something tiio said
today when he spoke he said you know
he's 39 he said please don't take my 40s
from me I would love to get married and
have children and you're going to he's
not going to come out he's like what 60
uh it's it's sad it's it's sad to see
someone have to be the scapegoat I mean
that's what the US government has done
to him I'm just going to I'm I'm going
to play the the the the time travel game
again because I love this game let's go
back to
2017 and I want you all to imagine going
to one of your friends and telling them
in
2023 six proud boys will receive multi-
deade sentences in prison for what the
government describes as an act of
domestic Terror to to overthrow the seat
of government and they would laugh
harder than anyone's ever laughing
they'd say you're a nut job the the guys
singing in the in the bar and marching
around in polar shirts and doing what
are they sing like Aladdin or something
proud of your boy or whatever it wasan
seriously you're out of your mind now
look where we are mhm well there uh go
ahead there was one guy who uh didn't
get charged who was in the capital that
day and that was Sergey debtim and he
was actually a Ukrainian asite soldier
who happened to find him self in the
capital that day and uh some photos were
uncovered of him this week by lur lomer
and it just I find it crazy that you
have Ukrainian spies that are in our
Capital infiltrating our seat of
government and they're not charged
they're allowed to come to the US
they're allowed to go protest in Orlando
this week with all those guys they're
allowed to go back to Ukraine but then
we have you know American citizens that
weren't even there and they're getting
20e sentences so this is interesting
Laura lomer posted this she says I've
exclusively confirmed the FBI identified
Ukrainian operatives and neo-nazis were
at the US capital on January 6 and even
questioned J Sixers about Ukrainian
spies during interviews with the FBI the
New York Times uh actually I'm sorry
this is Daily Dot not the New York Times
uh said why Ukraine is now being accused
of secretly orchestrating the capital
Riot can I just I want I want to explain
to you what they do it's one thing for
lur lummer to be like hey look at this
dude who is Ukrainian spy who appears to
have been at the capital isn't that
something crazy what do they say Ukraine
is now being accused of orchestrating
the capital Riot which is a massive leap
from what Laura lomer said this is how
they try to debunk The Narrative yeah
they create a conspiracy theory that no
one brought up and then claim it's
obviously insane right yeah here's the
tweet from Laura lumer she says during
the private interview with America
Shaman the FBI asked him how he knew a
Ukraine operative who took a photo with
him the day of j6 chanc he didn't know
the guy and the FBI confirmed Ukrainian
sery how do you pronounce his name de
deban something like that there's three
wi yeah it's a lot uh was a Ukrainian
spy who was affiliated with the Nazi aav
Battalion this means the US capital was
penetrated by Ukrainian spies I don't
know about spies but at least a spy and
the US government FBI have still not
arrested these people or made the public
aware of the foreign penetration it's an
act of War by Ukraine against the United
States and the US government has sent
200 billion to Ukraine in the last two
years the CIA is funding a color
revolution in the United States VI
Ukrainian Nazis and American Nazis who
are being recruited by the CIA etc etc I
do think a lot of this is a bit of a
stretch I think there's there's a fair
question of this does look like the same
guy are we absolutely sure it is him is
the question they said that the FBI and
the CIA asked him about this guy being a
UK so I mean make of Make of the you
know extrapolation what you will but the
fact that this guy was in our Capital
when all these other people are being
charged with Insurrection what do you
call that that I mean that is at its
core an act of War if there was Chinese
spies doing that what we we know what we
would call that but because it's Ukraine
and Ukraine is good we have to just sit
here and accept it yeah he just wandered
in he was a tourist there's he couldn't
have been there for any other reason
nothing could be
malicious I mean that's this is the
question about all of janary Sixers is
like we know the FBI had informants from
proud boys or Oath Keepers are different
groups we know that they had people on
the ground that day we know that the
mayor of DC and Nancy Pelosi were
offered uh to have additional security
and support of the capital and that was
turned down so if the government
intelligence unities knew this could
potentially happen and it was such a big
deal why didn't they stop it why did
they let it happen uh it for me that's
just evidence that it wasn't I mean my
one of my favorite lines from the
opening statements for the proud boys
trial was uh one of their lawyers can't
remember who at this moment said you
know she's reading these texts where
these guys are saying so what time
should we meet up in the morning where
where are you going to be like they they
didn't have a plan and she just said
this group couldn't organize a group
order at McDonald's like they did not
plan an insurrection they did not try to
overthrow the US government but I think
ultimately that's the narrative that you
know our intelligence Community really
needed to be the case that's why they
didn't intervene when theoretically they
should have if they knew it was going to
happen I do think things are going to
get a lot crazier in 2024 I think it'll
be more heavy-handed on on the side of
the left seeing these uh these far-
leftists be criminally charged with
domestic Terror in Rico good interesting
they're criminals who stormed a
government facility and firebombed
buildings houses Shad of Cups yeah they
need to be locked up the riers in front
of at January 6 who are smashing things
and trying to break their way yeah they
should be criminally charged too but
that's what 16 months for a violent Riot
and attacking cops not 20 years the
heavy-handedness is fairly obvious the
fact that Enrique tario according to
defense they said he wasn't even in
contact with them that day they gave him
22 years you know what I'll tell you was
really interesting about this is that
apparently there was a statement
released by uh Taro gave a statement to
the judge saying he regretted his
actions do you see this mhm and that um
you know he he was remorseful and he
shouldn't have done it he said that he's
not a political Zealot and he didn't
even know that you could over you could
change the results of an election and
that you know he shouldn't have compared
people to founding fathers or anything
like that I think and then the judge
apparently said he doesn't see any
reason why Enrique would be remorseful
over his actions or actually believe it
look man it's going to get crazier in
2024 it will get crazier we're already
seeing a whole bunch of videos of people
having their homes raided by feds now in
2023 2 and a half years later there's
how many people were there at the
capital we know that people who wandered
in Clueless you know a few hours after
the start of everything were criminally
charged and sentenced to a year or more
we know that the people who were
storming the front actually engaged in
violence have been criminal charged
criminally charged but there are
hundreds more maybe even a thousand more
who have not yet been charged who were
there and we starting to see these
videos pop up it seems that they waited
until the start of the election cycle
Joe Biden just announc I guess what he's
doing a $25 million ad bu for the next
campaign around the exact same time the
feds are starting to raid more people
for January 6 and don't you forget it
there were a lot of media personalities
social media figures who were cheering
on what was going on outside of what
Enrique tario did if they're claiming
I'll tell you this you guys if they're
claiming Enrique tario was was
organizing and inciting and encouraging
it so that he gets 22 years think about
what's going to happen to the people who
are on these alternative social media
platforms with thousands of viewers and
they were saying more more more do you
think that the the feds are going to
ignore that no I think next they're
going to come for media personalities we
know that James o'keef is being
investigated in New York not necessarily
related to January 6 but I think a large
component of what they're doing is going
to be the people on social media
encouraging it calling for more and
cheering people on they're going to say
we're part of a criminal conspiracy and
they were they were inciting and they
knew what they were doing Etc yeah I I
mean the this case is precedent setting
I mean so judge Kelly who was was
overseeing this trial said that he said
this in all of the sentencings but today
he was specifically saying our country
needs a peaceful transfer of power and
you broke our tradition of the peaceful
transfer of power and so he's basically
saying these are the people that ruined
democracy which seems bizarre to me
because it seems obvious that they did
not actually have a plan to do anything
yes they were going to a rally yes they
were in DC yes things got out of hand
they might need to face some charges but
the idea it was a conspiracy seems weak
anyways and in fact we have had peaceful
transfer transfers of power since right
we had midterms elections nobody rided
at the capital when Congress was sworn
in for the newest term like it seems
actually fine you want it to be that
there is more tension that's that that's
my editorial take on it that there is a
desire for there to be contention
between uh different political factions
and the only solution is we have to lock
some of you up right I mean like I've
been saying if your politicians can only
campaign on vote for me and I will go
after your enemies then that just
continues the escalation by the way is
what I think Biden can only campaign on
because we're about to have soon loan
debt repayments he couldn't get those
wiped away we're about to have I mean
inflation is not great we have tons of
Millennials who are saying I would love
to buy a home and I cannot Biden is not
um a healthy person he is polls
consistently show people think he is too
old to run again he is the oldest
sitting president in our nation's
history I think he is actually very weak
going into this campaign and that's why
magically this timing all lines up where
Trump Trump's indictment the proud boy
results I mean all of this is happening
at once I got my bribe from the uh Biden
Administration over the weekend I got a
letter that says they forgave $7,000 of
student loan debt I didn't ask I didn't
sign up for it I didn't want it and they
did it anyway because it had been 21
years the debts older than 20 years so
they just wiped it off and just such a
bribe I me just disgusting I thought
there was programs like that that have
existed for a while for like a decade at
least there's been programs to help
people who are lower income or whatever
those circumstances may be to help with
student loans so that's like I know
that's been a big point of contention
with people who are now uh finding fault
with Biden's plan because they're like
there's programs to help us they already
exist we're already doing handouts he
just wants the feather in his cap he
wants to say I'm the president that did
this yeah he wants he wants the bribe
well let's talk about this next story
from CNN outside of the criminal charges
and prosecutions we're seeing there is
another path the Democrats may take to
try and win in 2024 and that is mandate
and lockdowns first from CNN first lady
Jill Biden tests positive for Co 19 and
I have to wonder why report this story
why did the White House think it
necessary to tell the world they could
have just done nothing they could have
said you know Jill's taking vacation no
they wanted the world to know that she
is positive for Co 19 well a lot of
people immediately speculated this is it
it's how they reintroduce Co politically
at the start of the election cycle guess
what everybody Joe Biden announced
something like $25 million ad spend it
is beginning you're going to start
seeing all the news stories get planted
you're going to see political contention
you're going to see criminal charges
you're going to see conspiracy theories
you are going to see it all because
after this we got another story Biden
tests negative for coid will wear masks
when close to others White House says
and thus Begins the normalization of
everyone wearing masks again now Joe
Biden will be wearing masks in all of
his videos we've already all the videos
that he's in all the uh press statements
and everything he gives you've already
got schools and hospitals bringing back
masks now the president is doing it and
lastly Dr fouchy concerned people won't
comply if masking recommendations return
I hope they abide I love the story
because fouchi was saying the CDC
doesn't mandate masks and uh uh what he
said was they recommend them it's
actually the states or the private
sector that mandate The Masks so when we
talk about mandate coming back y'all
need to understand it is going to be the
chain store or restaurant that says
based on the recommendation by the CDC
you now must wear a mask when you come
into our store that is how they will
bring back mandates and they will say it
wasn't us who did it we didn't lock you
down the stores are choosing to do it
yep a keyword private sector right the
airlines are going to implement this
when the government says ooh remember
the last time we bailed you out not
going to happen again unless you uh make
some changes to your policies so the
private sector has the is their arms
being bent by the Biden Administration
so that's their tool to you know enforce
and get these things through to the
general public Tucker Carlson said he
doesn't think that they're going to do
the mandates again but uh more and more
evidence starting to pile up that
they're gearing up for lockdowns now the
other news of course ladies and
gentlemen this may come as a shock to
many of you whoopy Goldberg was absent
from the view that's right and uh Co she
tested positive for Co there was a
second one too the one of the other ones
tested positive apparently what if all
the view ladies have to quarantine
because they have Co what what are they
do then let me uh let me play the video
for you guys this is uh we have this
from Alx on Twitter listen to the
reaction by the audience of The View
when they get the news that whoopy has
Co and joy bear claims it's back um as
you can see whoopy is not here she has
coid yes it's back it's back it's back
but she's on the men she's on the tail
end and she probably back this week but
sorry she's not here for those of you
who are looking forward to seeing her
it's back they never left it's emic like
they made a point of saying it was
endemic like it's here forever so there
it is you know I just feel like the
culture war is divided amongst people
who seek out information to challenge
their views for the most part not always
and those who desperately don't want
their views challenged at all and just
want to be told what to do the people
watch The View they just want to be told
what to do yeah what to think what to
feel just tell me when to jump I don't
know I want to fit in it'll be easy and
then everyone else is like H let me
figure it out for
myself yeah you brought up the point
from Tucker Carlson that he does not
believe that mandates are going to come
back he did say that he'd be willing to
bet his house that we're going to enter
a hot war with Russia and that Biden's
going to use that as footing for the
election to manipulate control however
you know they see best fit but I'd
rather have this I don't I don't want to
have anything but I'd rather have this
hot war with Russia yeah I think both
might be true yeah could be I mean if if
we get involved in hot war with Russia
hold let's slow down even Tucker did
says we are at war with Russia that we
understand but like a formal actual
confrontation you know full scale or
whatever if that is to happen that's
what they'll do to try and win yes and
if that does happen where Biden comes
out there's going to have to be some
kind of attack on America it's going to
have to be whatever whatever may be a
legitimate maybe a false flag I'm I'm
just saying before the US can actually
formally engage in any way I'm not
saying formally declare but engage
there's got to be some public support
that results in a lockdown mhm they will
have to control things with an iron fist
in this country if they're going to
engage in direct conflict with Russia
but I don't know if they can I mean if
that was an audience of just average
Americans when uh the the ginger lady
when she said you know it's back you
would have heard average Americans laugh
that's what you would have heard that's
not your average American right there so
how do how do you impose that if most of
America is not on board I guess it's a
question of will enough people just
ignore it or not is fouchy are his fears
correct that people will not comply if
look I got to tell you out in West
Virginia you know if they if they that's
just not going to work yeah you're not
going to get it it's not going to happen
they can try in Maryland yeah in
Maryland it'll definitely happen because
the people in Maryland it's just it
really is interesting this divide there
are a lot of people in Western Maryland
who are uh you know it's MAA country but
then you go to the businesses and they
are on their knees begging begging the
government to tell them what to do and
it's just like weird yeah you cross that
River and then they're just like we
don't care what you do it's just we are
different cultures that live next door
to each other perhaps it's because you
know Baltimore more resources more money
more likely to be enforced people are
terrified West Virginia you're not
really going to see Heavy enforcement so
people just do whatever they want and
say I don't care do do something when we
when during the lockdowns and the
mandates I went to uh uh Maryland's
Panhandle was there was a bar in the
middle of nowhere and that ass signed
the door being like you know masks are
required as per state require like
regulation or whatever and then you walk
in no one's wearing a mask and the
bartenders just like washing a mug and
he's like looking left and right like
you know shrugging like whatever dude
nobody cares but the F the closer you
get to uh DC the more the businesses are
terrified screaming at you and kicking
you out I think it happens like they
want the conservative Boomers during the
Mas mandate period because I knew so
many Who would wear like a mask off
their ear and be like they said I had to
wear it but I don't want to like there
was this funny resistance around C there
were certain people who complied they
wanted you to wear four masks and then
there were other people who were like
this is dumb and I don't want to be
doing it and how effective can these
masks really be uh I think some of the
issue will come down to the state
Governors I think we I mean one of the
reasons we all know Ronda sanz's name is
because he was like yeah we're not doing
this and he deserves a lot of credit for
that I think this time around if there
were to be some sort of pressure for
mandates uh there would be a lot of
Governors who now see that if they say
no they are putting themselves in favor
of the majority of their constituents
it's all about the vision you know and
the lead up to uh you know 2020 if East
Tennessee did not look like Portland you
know there was not the same protest
there and it's all about div vision and
this time they're probably going to have
some sort of a lockdown or mandate or
whatever but it's going to be by area to
create theis vision and just cause
unrest and Chaos right before the
election again mhm I'd love to see uh
the inter us migration change too like
if there is a second lockdown that was
one of the biggest Trends I mean U-Haul
was constantly reporting this that the
the places people were leaving were
places that were more interested in
enforcing mandates I mean this could be
a way that especially rural States see a
population boom that they are not
expected to get but it's very hard to
with the economy the way it is and these
interest rates you're how are you
supposed to leave right now say I'm just
saying there are people who will be like
I'm not doing this again this is worth
the investment to well I think it was
very easy to say that the first time
around with the housing market just
being an absolute boom now it's very
it's much harder I shouldn't say it's
very hard everyone's got different
circumstance but it's a lot harder than
to just be like all right here we go to
West Virginia a lot of people are going
to be stuck with in areas that have
mandates we saw a lot of people leave
places like California and New York and
Illinois and go to Texas and Florida I'm
wondering how that affects their state
these states are not swing states by any
any stretch of the imagination I wonder
you know Texas is was turning purple now
it's now it's red Florida the same
thing New York Illinois and California
were never going to be red so these
moves they're making are actually
helping Donald Trump and Trump only lost
2020 by 42,000 votes between three
states if more people start moving to I
don't know Wisconsin Georgia or what's
what's the other what's the third state
Arizon I don't see how Trump loses
I I mean look Californians are moving to
Arizona and these and these are more
moderate to left leaning people who are
fleeing their own policies and they're
going to bring it to Arizona and they're
going to vote in to make things worse
Wisconsin I'm wondering are people from
Chicago leaving and then going to
Wisconsin voting for the same thing
there was that famous tweet where the
guy was like I'm leaving finally finally
I'm leaving California it's bad I'm
going to Florida and then people were
like you're going to Florida but Ronda T
is bad like oh don't worry I'll keep
voting the same way it's like oh okay
and then you're going to turn Florida
into California yeah thanks so much for
your support yep when it comes to these
uh the talk of government mandates I
feel like this is once a body develops
an immune response to a virus it just is
totally ready for that virus the next
time it comes around and this mind virus
of everybody get ready to be afraid get
ready to hide in your house from this
invisible thing like people are immune
it it doesn't mean that we're impervious
to it but people are done with it they
done with the they're done with
being told what to do they're done with
sitting in their house being
told they can't go outside they've had
it I I it is per this this Society is
resilient I'm I'm not convinced I I
witnessed it when you go to when when
when I would go to DC or or or Frederick
in Maryland and you would see these
businesses drop to their knees in two
seconds perhaps the people who Moved
feel the way you're describing it Ian
but now those people are in Florida and
they're in Texas and they're in West
Virginia the people who stayed are going
to do the exact same thing govern Me
Harder Daddy I was I was very positively
influenced by being at the airport and
seeing how few people actually had masks
a couple weeks ago yes but there's no
mandates the airport six people there's
no mandates I was at the Library of
Congress today and they have the big
rotunda where you know only researchers
are allowed no one's really allowed in
there with all the the books and
documents and stuff there was only three
people in that massive area now these
are supposed to be like smart
intelligent IV League people that get to
go into that room two out of the three
had masks on so bizarre it's insane
every one of those people in The View
there's saying oh no the mandates coming
back CO's coming back but I guarantee
you they went home and started to pull
up recipes for you know homem make you
know loaves of bread again as they're
waving their Ukraine Flags it's like
these people are happy they want to see
it happen because they love the control
people that are really intelligent but
very low wisdom they're very good at at
being told what to do and immediately
doing what they're told and mimicking
and remembering and then you know
playing back I I'm very good at this
know reward me I'm very good at doing
what I'm told those are that's the
danger of intelligence dude if people
love ratting on their neighbors people
in these cities are going to are going
to be vile they're going to join the mob
and if the mob says mask they're going
to say mask and then they're going to
celebrate anybody who dying who doesn't
MH it's tough to make this conversation
from the top I just to top down like
talk about other people because I I
think people my guess is that if anyone
feels as remotely as fed up with it as I
do that there's no way in hell this is
going to get off the ground again I I
barely had to touch the masks years BR
people didn't like it in the first place
yeah but they thought they were doing
good in the first place and now they
know they weren fear I mean people were
told if you come anywhere near your
grandmother she'll immediately die it
was like insane amount of information
it's it's not even that it's that the
government came and issued fines and
arrested people a woman who is who is uh
selling products from her store on the
internet on Facebook had the cops show
up and threaten her with charges unless
she stopped doing Facebook live
the reason these people cave and gave up
is not because they they all of them are
celebrating it's because these cops are
going to come and they're going to beat
the crap out of you there's a salon how
many salon owners like two or three got
arrested a guy giving haircuts in
Michigan got arrested a woman in uh what
was it she fled Minnesota to Iowa and
then the sheriff tracked her down and
arrested her because she opened her
coffee shop during lockdowns there will
be some people but that terrifies people
so you you go to these big Urban these
big cities where it takes one guy to
destroy your life by destroying your
business and these people will drop to
their knees in two seconds and say we
will do whatever you say government
except the government really up
last time the cops going in there it
pisses me off so much dude get it man
the the cops would go in there and be
like you can't open your business the be
people be like yeah I can and they be
like No in fact we're doing what's good
for you we're shutting your business
down the person's like now I'm out of
money the cop's like good we've done our
job job like that doesn't you can't you
can't do that to someone twice you
cannot they they've already you've
already shocked everybody away yeah but
the the cops uh either quit or fired the
the the ones that were on the side of
Freedom I'll say right I mean we had
mandates not just to wear masks but also
to get the vaccine so it's like a lot of
people said no and they lost their job
over it those cops are gone we don't
have them the cops that are still
employed are ones that are just doing it
for a paycheck or said yes government
I'll do whatever you want look at these
videos of how they arrest these J Sixers
it's like there's some just like a dude
there's like a video of a guy going to a
grocery store or something and they run
up with like rifles pointed at them like
dude these These are drone gestapo
morons working for these agencies they
don't care they don't know it feels good
to be in charge of you it feels good to
them I mean these are these are people
who are not satisfied by their own
accomplishments or they're they're
Satisfied by feeling like they can do
whatever they want to you that so what
ends up happening is you get a small
business and they might say something to
you like I really hate it but I have no
choice they're going to find me that's
what everyone kept saying and I I I see
this now we talk about it quite a bit
James O'Keefe had a really great tweet
and he posted it on Instagram and he
said you are responsible for whatever
life your children inherit that all of
these people who are saying I can't
stand up for what I believe in because I
have kids and they're putting my kids at
risk then you are directly responsible
for what what the the Li your children
inherit when they are living under the
boot of Communists who are laughing at
them the party members who get special
favors or food it's going to be
because you you allow this by saying you
know I'll just I'll just I'll just
comply I'll just I'll just give in I I'm
not saying I have all the answers I
think typically you know I I think come
2024 the reason we're seeing a lot of
this Extreme Action is because if Donald
Trump's right as of right now if the
election were held today Trump wins
that's what the polls are saying right
now that's what the analytics are saying
that's what the forecast models are
saying it doesn't mean he does win but
that's why you're seeing the machine of
the Democrats panic and need something
to force people into fear or you know I
I guess more Extreme Action when I look
at these videos of the J Sixers being
having the feds come up and point guns
at them I'm like they are hoping for
some kind of reaction from from these
people don't give it to him all you got
to do is
just make money succeed push back back
and resist where you can and then make
sure you're spreading the word as much
as possible there are a lot of people
who are like this this weird game where
they're saying Tim saying not to do
anything no I'm quite literally saying
resist where possible succeed make money
build influence build culture and then
come 2024 get everyone you can to vote
in overwhelming numbers Trump only needs
42,000 votes and Biden's going to lose a
lot more than that that's not a
guarantee that Trump fixes anything it's
not a guarantee that Trump actually
comes and saves the day at all but but
it is a start I think that's what they
fear that's why they want a reaction and
you can't give it to
them yeah we got to govern ourselves
outside of politics that's for sure I I
got a question if you've been traveling
a lot all over the country recently with
you know let's say for this year so far
in 2023 what happens if they start bring
you know they bring back mask mandates
for trains and planes what I'm curious
to how you'd handle it because it would
derail your life or you'd have to comply
well I I try not to answer questions
with premises I don't agree with and I
feel like accepting the premise that
there's going to be a shutdown just
makes it more likely shut down different
from mask mandates i' just stop Flying
I'm almost I'm I'm about ready to stop
traveling anyway but yeah I'll just
completely stop shut private only you
know a lockdown a CO lockdown is very
different from mask mandates the mask
mandates seem very likely there are
still businesses all over Maryland with
signs saying You must wear masks and
those colleges in Atlanta were like he's
put a mask on I mean there some
institutions are already rolling it out
in some capacity so it doesn't seem
impossible that it'll spread uh I just
think it'll be very Regional I think
that there will be you know certain
sectors of the country that say yes and
certain that say no and you know I hope
that everyone gets to live in a
community that's reflects their values
um and I think Tim's totally right there
there is it's sort of like testing the
boundaries there's going to be a push to
have to see what you will be okay with
and what your reaction would be and you
have to just stay in control as much as
possible it'll be interesting because I
think if the bid Biden already saying
he's wearing masks it does please a lot
of partisan liberal types but it will
push away moderates and independents so
in that regard I don't know how this
plan is ultimately going to help them
unless they're using it to ramp up some
kind of new expansive voting policy for
2024 it is kind of late though we're a
few months away from 2024 and the the
election Cycle's already begun so any
rule changes will have to come they do
it quick they can do it quick New
Zealand Australia whatever they they had
those uh coid camps and blink of an eye
you know things can change very quickly
I want to jump to this next story from
Newsweek Russians start start a hot war
with Russia I think it's fair Tucker
does mention this we're we're at war
with Russia and anybody saying otherwise
is lying us Personnel is on the are on
the ground volunteers they're using us
equipment they're trained by NATO
they're trained by the US they're
provided intelligence by the US missiles
by the US the UK sending depleted
uranium tank Busters yeah it is NATO
versus Russia it's a proxy war well now
we have this story this could be
Newsweek and uh uh Western media trying
to ramp up fear that there is a reason
to go to war with Russia you I'll give
you the long the long story short of it
you have uh this guy it's not it's not
it's corenko right yes editor of the na
newspaper National Defense he basically
said Russia is being warned and
threatened that if we misbehave or if
you know Ben Haj is a opinion we exceed
what he considers to be the necessary
permissible lines the use all for the
use of all types of Russian weapons he
threatens us with more than just strikes
on the Crimean Bridge he responds by
basically saying if you engage in war
with us we will not go to war with the
US in Europe we will go to war with the
US on US Territory he says in response
to your attacks on Russian military or
civilian facilities the first strike
will be a preventative limited strike
against Targets on the territory of the
United States of America I think it's
s uh they point out in Newsweek and a
couple other outlets the most effective
way to use nuclear weapons by the
Russians is to claim they have them and
that's it but it makes no sense to
Target us civilian uh territorial
targets because all that would do is
make their position in in in Eastern
Europe worse I agree Russia has no
reason to do this this is some random
guy that goes on Russian State tv maybe
he's looking for a better paying job and
he's trying to come out and say but the
fact of the matter is Russia controls
87,000 Square km of Ukrainian territory
the you know the ratio of Russian troops
to Ukrainian troops loss is insane
Ukraine's lost 400,000 Plus Men Russia
maybe 150,000 they have no reason to do
something as Extreme as this and that
really wouldn't be in Putin's you know
line of governance either Let's uh let's
make all of the corporate media Outlets
uh happy and give them an article to
write about yeah what's the likelihood
you think that that the US would engage
in a false flag to justify expansive uh
expanding the war in Ukraine
I think they already did I mean that was
2014 when the maidon massacre took place
the Western press all said it was a
bunch of uh you know Ukrainian
government yanukovich aligned
individuals that rain down with sniper
fire on the protesters in made on Square
12 years later we learned that it was
actually Georgian Legion snipers that
were out there nine years nine years
nine years later
2014 nine years later it was Georgian
snipers that were out there at the beest
of the Ukrainian Now new Ukrainian
government you know we know that for for
sure I've not heard that yeah Canadian
researcher look him up he did the study
it was Georgian snipers that did it also
in Oliver Stone's documentary he touched
on that subject but the snipers were
firing from the the buildings around
maid on Square that were controlled by
the a of aligned individuals within the
grab for power so here's all I can say
as to that claim
Western media Outlets say that it's
propaganda issued by Russia and Russian
Outlets say it's confirmed So This Is
War it's War who you people will die
people yeah but just like the idea that
uh I will say it's it's not above any
Waring Nation to engage in a false flag
especially as it pertains to
overthrowing a government the us is
going to claim and Western powers are
going to claim this is what the the
Russian align government was doing and
Russia's going to claim it was Western
forces trying to over overthrow the
government andall their their their
their puppet and then also I mean look
at this you have the uh you know I won't
give my full opinion on YouTube but you
have the nordstream pipeline incident
and you had everyone in the west who's
saying that was Russia it was definitely
Russia and I think everyone knows who it
really was you can look at the uh the
Kremlin drone attack they were saying
that was a false flag by Russia then we
turn to find out that the Ukrainian
government put a postage stamp out
celebrating a Ukrainian Soldier flying
the drone over the Kremlin and bombing
it I mean the list goes on I'm sure
Russia maybe they this is warse FL
happen but absolutely let's clar we have
this from The Washington Post us had
intelligence of detailed Ukrainian plan
to attack nordstream pipeline the CIA
learned last June via a European spy
agency that a six person team of
Ukrainian Special Operations forces
intended to sabotage the Russian to
Germany natural gas project they claimed
over and over and over again that Russia
did it they even speculated that Russia
could have Dropped a Bomb through the
pipeline so we got to that point it blew
up which makes literally no sense
Russia Vladimir Putin being like I have
the perfect way to defeat my enemies
I'll blow up my own oil pipeline what it
didn't make any sense and yet this was
the all of the western media was like
that's the only explanation Russia must
have done it and then slowly it of sort
of came out that oh actually that's this
thing that seems improbable is actually
probably not true yeah it was a it you
know it it was what it was whoever did
it I mean that's the CIA Washington Post
saying it was Ukraine who did it Seymour
hirs has other ideas you know Biden
Administration but at its core what
happened with that I mean it was an
escalation of War it prevented Germany
from being able to negotiate with the
Russians by turning the Taps back on for
the nordstream pipeline and it made a
real big issue for Europe they had to
buy Russian liquefied natural gas they
bought 40% more liquefied natural gas
from Russia in the EU over the past year
so I mean it just caused prices to go up
you have the German economy you have the
French economy you have the Italian
economy that are all in shambles right
now Europe is in an inflationary crisis
they're about to be in a recession
Germany's already in a recession I mean
it's quite clear what's happening what
do you think is the uh
ideal circumstance right now related to
the war in in in Ukraine like how a
peace deal resolution yeah how like but
but what is it I mean I think I think if
you listen to Putin which no one in the
western press and Western governments
they try not to you know I think he's
quite clear about the fact that uh this
87,000 square kmers of territory they've
already taken is formerly now part of
the Russian Federation and it should be
respected as such the former French
president has come out last week and
said that you know there should be
formal referendums in these regions to
actually decide whether or not they want
to join Russia uh we've already seen
these elections though and they they
weren't internationally regulated but
these people said they wanted to join
the Russian Federation and I think
Russia is not going to stop and try for
a peace deal again until they get nikol
and Odessa which will land lock Ukraine
and also get the hark of region in the
Northeast I think once they get that
maybe they'll try to push for peace
proposals again but until then I mean it
it's going to be it's going to be the
same old same old people unfortunately
are going to die because no one in the
west is serious about pushing for peace
can I ask what are the major differences
between the Soviet Union and modern day
Russia um well the main differences I
think um I don't know I think the Union
was pretty base but I think that the
Russian economy today if you look at the
economy if you talk about that uh what
what is the basis of the Russian economy
well you know Soviet Union at its start
the country was at its knees you had
basically a feudal society and the
Soviet Union took it from took it from
its knees to a war superpower won the
second world war at the cost of 27
million people but it also centralized
the important sectors of government and
we're seeing that in Russia today
instead of in the United States where we
have all these these rapacious you know
private companies that are hoarding our
our resources hoarding our oil hoarding
our gas hoarding our coal whatever in
Russia they have it under a public
structure you know it's under the
government and they can actually you
know utilize these systems to benefit
the people and negotiate with other
countries like bricks Partners In terms
that are going to be beneficial to the
Russian economy and the central bank and
that's what's happening with bricks you
know they're they're expanding very fast
W this is this is this is this this
matters a lot pull up check take a look
at this from the BBC Russian military
control look at this they have all going
all the way down to Curson nearly nearly
to Odessa all of Crimea and everything
is under Russian military control we
keep getting told or we've been told
over and over again that the ukrainians
are pushing back but it really feels
like what they're doing is for every 10
10 conflicts that arise let's say 10
battles Ukraine wins one that gets
reported in the press and so everything
we hear is like they're they're counter
offensive is working they're gaining
ground this is crazy anybody who's been
keeping track of this I mean look is
Russia's basically won they've taken the
donbest they've taken the land bridge to
Crimea they've got it and it's not over
yet and not just that but the cities
that Ukraine is taking uh if you look at
the pre-war populations for these cities
it's like it's like 50 homes 400 people
maybe a few Farms it's nothing uh in
this big counter offensive that we put
all this money to Ukraine hasn't even
reached the first line of Russian
defense fortification
they have three lines of defense
fortifications that they've been
building up since last November behind
those three lines they have tens of
thousands of reservist and then back in
Russia they have even more reservist
soldiers than Russian soldiers in the
whole of Ukraine right now so it's only
going to go in one way it's going to go
I guess two ways maybe however Russia
wants this to end or mutually assur
destruction whatever whatever happened
with the bmot situation cuz I know that
just was in the news for the Ukraine war
for a while and now PR which I'm also
curious to your thoughts about how
that's all played out what's the deal
with bmot because I feel like we've
almost seen a stalemate there's been no
progress either way at least someone
from as a casual Observer of what's been
happening in the war so yeah I'm curious
to your thoughts uh Wagner under the
leadership of progan uh so when he was
still alive you know months ago they
they fully liberated the city they took
it 100% so none of it remains in
Ukrainian control there's still some
firefighting on like the flanks the
outside regions of bakut or timos and uh
basically what's going to happen over
the next several months is the Russians
are about to start an offensive of their
own because they defeated the counter
offensive from Ukraine they're going to
focus on the flanks of they're going
to focus on maybe hon and they're
definitely going to focus on taking back
the whole strip of land in the Northeast
the hark of region they're going to
probably take all of that back and then
we'll have some down period and then
next spring is when you're going to have
the large blow out of the Russian
soldiers pushing in the South all the
way through h to Odessa they're going to
completely landlock it and take all of
that okay it's kind of crazy to see you
know cuz I've not been actively tracking
the maps of control but they kept saying
that Ukraine's winning Russia's losing
they're on the verge of defeat they're
they kept saying that Russia is
suffering massive casualties and like
let's oper under the assumption that the
reporting about massive Russian
casualties was correct and Ukraine was
winning how does Russia now have total
milit military control of the land
bridge to Crimea and then some and it's
not like this is you know under contest
in marup Russia's already gone in
they've built new schools new grocery
stores new hospitals they've built free
apartments for the people there they're
happy you know and and the the numbers
are lies as I'm sure you know we can all
assume they lie about everything in the
mainstream press I mean Ukraine's lot
it's it's like a generation of men
400,000 men Russia's got four times the
population of Ukraine how could anyone
ever expect that Ukraine was going to
win I saw a meme that could be
propaganda who knows and it was a a a
4chan green text where it was a
Ukrainian dude and he was like you know
one year ago I'm I'm I'm engaged about
to get married I'm working at my job
making an okay wage everything's fine
he's like today log on to social media
and see my my fiance dancing in a
dress in Germany having a party at at a
at a rave and I just got my draft papers
I'm going to be sent to the front lines
where I'll probably die why is my life
like this yeah the people people there
at I mean I got to be honest the people
I knew fled the people that I knew from
Ukraine aren't there anymore and they're
posting pictures on the beach and other
places and I'm just like what is Russ
Russia is moving in they're taking and
I'm just seeing the media lie about
what's going on every step of the way
how do we end this and just say enough
because at this point I don't see an
argument based on this map for Russia
gives up territory at one in a military
conflict you lost perhaps a peace deal
could have happened a long time ago
before Boris Johnson destroyed it and
then you could have actually preserved
some of this land under Ukrainian
control or prevented the death of people
and seated it in the first place I don't
see how this ends well for the rest of
Ukraine or for NATO I do honestly think
that if if us interest in NATO refuse to
let go of this it's going to escalate
into a more direct conflict I think it
depends on who gets elected Trump said
he sounds insane when he says I'm going
to end the war in 24 hours right I it
but yeah of course we believe it because
if you withhold funding for Ukraine
their government collapses in hours
their government employees their
soldiers their pensions their
firefighters their police the corrupt
people you know stripping people off the
streets to go on the front they're all
funded by the US taxpayer so they
collapse within hours if we stop and
Trump said he's going to put a peace
deal forward if Ukraine doesn't like it
that's the end I I think that the moment
they announc Trump as the protected
winner Russ Russia immediately says
ceasefire because we know what happens
when Trump comes in and we want
goodfaith efforts to to to put an end to
this and I think Ukraine agrees knowing
their funding is about to end and it's
time to find a safe way to to to retreat
Donald Trump gets on the phone I bet I
bet the moment Trump wins he's on the
phone saying we're going to have once
I'm officially in in hands on the Bible
this is done you know I bet they'll try
and get him on the Logan act or
something before he's he's brought into
office they'll try and stop it but I
think the moment Trump is in office he
gets on the phone and says there's no
more war we're negotiating tonight I'm
flying out he flies out it's over like
you said he cuts the US cuts off funding
Ukraine there's no war anymore yeah mhm
either that or it continues to escalate
as you said I mean the Russians they're
27 million people serious to protecting
their civilization that's how many they
roughly lost in World War II and they
see this as a similar threat so they've
lost 100,000 men so far who cares I mean
that's sad that's terrible but they're
willing to go a lot further to protect
their country their civilization and
their their land than 100,000 men and
they have the population and resources
to commit to that so in in we we've
heard uh what we've heard from the press
the corporate press United States is
that L Putin's evil and he's like Hitler
he wants to steal land that seems a bit
one-dimensional even if that is the case
and you genuinely believe Putin is just
evil and says now's my chance to steal
Land There is a goal to the land they're
taking and a strategic value to what
they're doing we don't hear it that
often in the general messaging from the
Press much like with the war in Iraq
they hate us for our freedoms which was
completely meaningless to people who
paid attention but sure worked on those
who didn't I'm curious uh from your
point of view why did Russia invade and
what is their goal and and and what are
they ultimately hoping to achieve now to
put it as quickly as possible Ukraine is
not a sovereign country it it's just not
a real country anymore it wasn't since
the US came in and toppled their
government in 2014 14 you have a
sovereign government tople your your
country do away with any form of you
know elected representation say this
guy's leading your country now if you
don't like it you know they're going to
sick these asite or right sector thugs
on you in the dbass they killed 15,000
individuals in the fighting many of whom
were civilians in the dbass from 2014
when the coup took place to 2022 the
Communist Party of the Russian
Federation is the second largest party
in Russia they were begging Putin to go
in and and save these people in the
dbass the past eight years they were
saying you're insane why AR you doing
anything why aren't you withholding
energy to Ukraine why are you doing
something so they were very critical the
other fact here is that in 1991
Secretary of State James Baker said NATO
is not going to extend one inch East
Pass of Germany they violated that
promise I think like 16 or 18 times now
they got all the way to Ukraine that was
the red line boom I mean that that's
that and uh the the violence didn't stop
the escalation continued up until the
week in which this war started but again
I don't think this war started on
February 24th 2022 I think it started
back in 2014 when a foreign government
came in seize power and started to
commit violence against any distance in
the state of
Ukraine but is that do you think that
the goal of Russia is to OU the
Ukrainian government and to establish
like a legitimate government or is it
actually to control the land into Crimea
that's what it it strikes me that that's
what they're looking to get I think
multiple things can be true at once you
can also that the land that Russia sees
it's resourcer that's 12.4 M or 12.4
trillion in resources in that 87,000
square kilom so multiple things can be
true at once but yeah I think the end
goal here is to have a government in Kev
that is not backing Nazi thugs that are
killing people in the dbass and I think
yanukovich was a guy who was CED he
wasn't explicitly Pro Russian uh but he
was also looking at EU contracts doing
deals with the EU and integration with
the EU I think Russia just wants someone
that's going to be fair in there but if
it comes to force and forcibly putting
someone in I think we can all assume
it's going to be someone who is going to
be Pro Russian do they ever talk
publicly about their War goal the
Russian Federation of course what is
their stated goal uh State a goal is
denazification of Ukraine H do away with
all these you know these Nazi battalions
Nazi political parties from 2014 to 2018
there was a good deal Nazis within the
Ukrainian government 2018 onward it
wasn't the case but the chair of the VAV
Narada in Ukraine from 2014 to 2018 uh
he was a self I mean self-described Nazi
this guy said well I don't know if I
should say that here I'm not going to
say it but you can look it up online for
yourself uh these are people who really
profess these views you see the videos
that Laura lomer posted in in Orlando
this week of these guys with swasa
chains and they're saying you know we
support Joe Biden because he's sending
Rockets to the ukrainians these are the
guys that are fighting over there these
are guys in government and the vad
Narada and they're trying to strip the
Russians of their ability to speak
Russian in Russia all that stuff right
so densification demilitarization is the
other goal stated goal of the Russians
that's just simply dealing with NATO and
saying you can't come over here you
can't put nukes right on our border with
they're going to be so close you know
they they said that the US said that
during the Cuban Missile Crisis that the
nukes in Cuba or the missiles in Cuba
that was you know a threat those were
putting uh missiles right in our
backyard well I mean like if you look at
Ukraine they're how close they are to
Russia I mean it's right on the border
and you're going to put nukes there
that's basically putting nukes in
someone's living room how do you think
this ends however Russia wants it then
based on well so what does that mean
does that mean Russia takes all of
Ukraine I think I think if the
warmongers keep doing what they're doing
you're going to have Poland that move
because they're building up Poland as an
economic power they're trying to topple
Germany France Italy they're
restructuring the EU Poland's going to
move into Western Ukraine laiv with the
consent of the US in the Deep State
Russia will take again if this happens
Russia will take everything including
Kiev and um you know Kevin Rose it used
to be Russian yeah so it could happen
right on well let's I was just going to
ask where zalinsky goes but we can move
on I mean a prison I'm I'm imagining we
take him as a refugee cuz he's on this
like PR tour you know he's an actor yeah
sure but let's jump to this next story
with the hard segue axios reports Elon
Musk threatens to sue the ADL after
blaming it for xad sales slump the long
story short is that he said that uh ad
revenue is still down by 60% primarily
due to pressure on advertisers by the
Anti-Defamation League that's what
advertisers tell us so now he's talking
about potentially suing the ADL and this
is big part of this Elon Musk has said
there will be a data dump on all
Communications between the ADL and
Twitter before he took
over holy crap if there are people who
ran businesses on Twitter who use
Twitter for a marketing tool or for
awareness building whatever that's real
monetary value and if the ADL contacted
Twitter to have them banned I'd argue
there's a very strong torous
interference claim and if Elon Musk
releases all the communications the ADL
had with Twitter the ADL thought it was
safe we talk to Twitter we tell them hey
this person should be banned Twitter
says okay they get banned ADL is not
scared that Twitter would ever leak
those Communications Elon Musk buys
Twitter and now he can open the
floodgates if he releases these
communications the ADL could be sued
into
Oblivion by every account by you your
your username could have been Maga Trump
for Life 773 whatever with underscore
seven and you have like an your avatar
was just a cartoon of
trump they go to Twitter and say ban
this person and you can argue they're
interfering interfering they're defaming
me me and they're interfering in my
agreement that I have with Twitter that
I'm using for my business or whatever it
may be now that may be a bit of a
stretch but there are a lot of accounts
that had 100,000 followers that made
money on the platform either uh selling
T-shirts or doing streams or collecting
donations and their business was
destroyed by the ADL interfering in the
existing agreement they had with Twitter
in fact if you look at Alex Baron this
one's really interesting not that the
Ada comes into play a role here this is
the government but this is a guy who has
uh I don't know if at the time he had a
substack but you you you you presumably
you're selling subscriptions on substack
the government comes in and says ban
this guy even though he didn't break any
rules so what happens he files a lawsuit
he wins his account gets reinstated
imagine all of the accounts targeted by
the ADL who did not break the rules but
got taken down because the ADL
threatened to lie about Twitter and
claim they were sewing hate or whatever
El mus about to open the floodgates
again this could be really really big I
hope he does to I think that's one of
the best things that could happen I
think one of the uh one of the
kryptonites of the American social media
General culture is that there are people
who can say this person is bad and you
should never speak to them you should
never have them on your platform and
that can have a Rippling effect I mean
maybe it's Anonymous account but maybe
it's just someone who posts under their
real name the ADL which has its own
political bias doesn't like them well if
you're banned from Twitter what stops
you from being banned from payout PayPal
from MailChimp from all of these other
organizations that say we heard that you
were bad we heard that you're not we're
not allowed to support you I mean there
is a really serious ripple effect that
damages free spe in's culture and the
ADL has been at the center of it for a
long time I love the idea that the ADL
Anti-Defamation League could get sued
for defamation yeah so people are
calling them the defamation league but
they they've been sued I guess for
defamation before 20 some OD years ago
they had to pay a fine I don't know
exactly what happened with that but this
is a key component to the narrative
manipulation in this country
organizations like the ADL and the splc
lie lie lie lie lie lie all the time and
um that's a fact Southern Property Law
Center has had to apologize the ADL has
also had to apologize uh for for putting
out false
information but this is what they do uh
the example I gave earlier is that
there's this group called the election
Integrity partnership that accused me of
being a super spreader of fake news and
this is why I use newsguard because now
my response to them is just oh I don't
know take a look at newsguard who
certified everything you said was fake
news and then ask them why they claimed
it was legitimate news don't look at me
all I can do is use newsguard but the
game they play is they never exactly
said what fake news it was I was
spreading the ADL will accuse you behind
the scenes you won't even know about it
and then the news reports come out
saying you did thing or were accused of
it they'll come out and say after being
uh you so- and so got banned for hate
speech and then it's just like what did
you actually say doesn't matter then the
media can report it then regular people
hear it and then they start making
assumptions about you for a lot of
people like uh for instance we had Steve
Bannon on the show the first time he was
on this show I got a message I got tons
of messages from people saying they
never they thought he was crazy they
never actually heard him speak there was
a meme that they had on Reddit
circulating and it was a picture of
Bannon that said this man thinks his
race is superior to yours and it's like
Steve B is not a white supremacist he
doesn't think that they make this stuff
up they hire people to spread
disinformation then they attack social
media organizations to get you banned so
you can't defend yourself mhm MH and and
it's able to happen because it's
government utilizing private compan
compes to attack you know what would
otherwise be definitely Free Speech uh I
got the Ukrainian government put me on a
kill list and then I got banned from
yeah PayPal vinmo twitch I got banned
from all these things after that so I
don't know maybe we could talk but I
think the I think the most interesting
answer to this and obviously any pro any
solution is going to have problems but
if you fully nationalize big Tech and
take it away from these private
corporations wouldn't Free Speech have
to be at least in maybe a better way
than it is today protected on these
platforms I don't really want Biden
Administration administering uh Free
Speech they have their own own position
on who gets to speak freely and who
doesn't but and they don't take like
Medicare away from people in the United
States because at least yet because you
have different political views maybe in
Canada they do that but not they do
Target your taxes based on your
political views they do do that you're
right not a perfect solution but you you
I don't know it's worth thinking about I
don't think I think it would create
another Monopoly controlled by the
government but the idea of forcing these
private companies to free their software
code to the people as like a government
action could could work because once you
have access to the devices or the
material software code you can make your
own version of the site and it can't ban
you I was going to say if the government
owns social media platforms it's too
much like Ministry of Truth for me I I'd
rather have someone
private neither are ideal but
government's like the worst option yeah
it's just not going so well in China you
know no I I I I don't NE necessarily
agree if uh there was a social media
that was run like a public utility that
was maintained by by by government
workers it's it's very difficult for
them to come and shut off your water or
something like that the idea would be
only under strict specific regulations
could they take your your your account
down like with a warrant right don't get
me wrong sorry just there will be
corruption search warrants are required
to break into your house or for the cops
to come in and they might be able to get
a bunk warrant signed by a bad judge but
if your account is up and you incite or
commit a crime through you know saying
hey everyone goes do this at this time
they go to a judge get a warrant the
judge says take it down they take it
down then you go and they can arrest you
or whatever but it could theoretically
work it I think it could and it's the
problems you guys brought up it's the
same exact problems we have today like
when I got banned from twitch one of my
viewers did a foyer request found out
the the organization that wrote the
whole article to get me banned from
twitch was in Communications with the
Department of Homeland Security they're
going back and forth and suggesting
names to get taken down from these
platforms over Russian disinformation so
you still you have those problems today
and I think You' have those problems if
you nationalize Twitter or Facebook or
whatever but I think they would be far
less and if they did happen you could
always do a Foye request kind of like
kind of like with Healthcare like a
public private thing where you still
have private healthcare insurance you
still have private social media but then
you could have a public social media
software X but yeah you'd have some sort
of Regulation but you don't actually
need government to run it you could
simply have regulation that states
accounts can be taken down without a
warrant signed by a judge so then for
someone so we have these we've talked
about this quite a bit actually uh in
New York for instance occupied Wall
Street took place on what's called a
pops a publicly owned private space so
the land is owned by an organization an
entity but you can use it because of an
agreement they have with the city which
grants them certain liability
protections but also grants you free
speech rights even though it's owned by
somebody so Elon Musk can monetize can
put ads up he's the owner but he can't
remove people because he's made an
agreement on liability that's the way it
should be mhm when occupied Wall Street
happened they said we want to remove
these people and they're like there was
a lawsuit and they're like you can't
it's a public space so free speech is
allowed you can't just claim private
private property after the fact the same
thing should be true for Twitter once
you're signed up and on you have free
speech they can't remove you unless you
commit a crime and they get a warrant
yep I was going to say it seems like
social media your rights the rights of
free speech aren't being extended online
fully as you know like you can go
outside of a Starbucks C and and you
could say whatever you want can't say
whatever you want uh you know on Twitter
so I think if we fully extended those
rights we wouldn't need to even have you
know the government take over you don't
even you don't even need government
maintaining it like these public these
these privately own public spaces are
maintained by the organizations that own
them and there's some benefit usually
like a tax they get a tax write off or
something they don't got to pay taxes on
it because it's open to the public but
then they pay to maintain it in the
instance of of Twitter they get the
lawsuit protections you're not
responsible for what anybody says you
can sell the ads but you also can't
remove people unless they're breaking
the law there are challenges with that
but I think the issue then gets to what
we've talked about before if you go in
public and you wave a a big a poster
with porn on it you're going to get
arrested on obscenity charges or
something they're going to take it
they're going to rip pull the sign down
they're going to say you can't do that
Twitter should be the same thing I don't
understand how we got to the point where
we as a society still recognize you
can't go out in public and show loot
images in the and wave them around in
the air but on Twitter you can on any
social media platform why is that you
got to pay you have to show an ID to get
into a bar you got to show ID to get
into a casino you can't even walk
through a casino unless you're 21 you
can't even bring your kids to the
restaurant so a lot of casinos will do
this thing where the where the
restaurant is actually just on the other
side of the security line so families
can actually bring their kids yet when
it comes to looking at adult graphic
content on the internet there's no
requirements yeah that's nonsense yeah
no it's crazy and it you know other
countries aren't like that in Asia China
you don't have you don't have that that
sort of stuff Russia is doing away with
that stuff and I think I think at its
core this this the question of this uh
issue of um # ban the ADL it's like all
of these issues of foreign or domestic
interference in private companies is
completely legal there's no first
amendment protection but Tim like you
said if you have some sort of a some
sort of a structure in place there that
guarantees Free Speech it would do away
anytime you have someone getting banned
taken off for something other than
explicit content or illegal CL criminal
activity you know that's immediately a
free speech issue I want to jump to this
story let's get cultural we have this
one from the gamer.com they say
Starfield isn't woke you're just afraid
of the future now uh many of you may not
be familiar with Starfield it's a video
game and a controversy has emerged
because you can choose your pronouns in
the game another game just came out
called balder's gate which is also
sparking some uh uh uh some culture War
outrage that I think is worth talking
about because it was a funny meme and it
said uh gamers are entering the culture
War you know what is it what what's
going to happen now and it's like
gamergate was the beginning of the
culture War when when people playing
video Gamers got upset over a variety of
issues including uh gaming companies
paying media Outlets to write favorable
reviews for them but this is what
happened here's the story Starfield has
PR actually uh Ian can you explain what
Starfield is Starfield is a game by
Bethesda it's their newest launch so
like Elder Scrolls and Fallout this is
the new one and it's a space game where
you can fly around from planet to planet
and experience different biomes I think
it's first person first new uh IP by
Bethesda in 25 years you've actually
been playing it Kell you said yeah yeah
uh I've not really encountered any
wokeness I mean the pronouns thing was
already default to he him so I didn't
even touch it when I started the game
but I'm curious what this article talks
about because so far I've enjoyed it I
haven't run into any nonsense is it like
Fallout like exactly so what Fallout 76
should have been except in space like it
just works well you know it's very in
depth I like it so far they say shortly
after Early Access began this weekend a
clip went viral featuring a bald British
man screaming about how Starfield is
desperate to remind us of the current
day with it use of pronouns and body
diversity they say hundreds of years in
the future a universe that reflects the
progress made within our own allows
players select the pronouns people in
their lives choose to address them this
choice is respected and is an obvious
component of making your character in
The RPG's opening moments so uh I I I
got a question pronouns are only used
not in your presence or if someone's
speaking about you with not with you not
privy to the conversation how does it
work in a video game when it's a first-
person game and you're involved in every
conversation they'll probably talk about
you in front of you and they'll be like
to prove they're doing it Z doesn't want
to go over there anymore can you type in
your pronoun or do you want a list you
can select from uh I think it's a list
dude I got to say I watched I watched
the intro I watched f p time play I
think it was P time play the intro and
it was it was rough man it was like woke
it was like girl boss this old woman
Starfield was yeah is like the boss and
she has no Charisma and you're like why
is this woman the main character right
now and then this dude this beta dude
comes up and he's like I'm going to give
you my ship for no reason and that's the
that's the beginning of the game and
then it just dumps you and it's like wow
this is like well that's the beauty of
the game is you can completely take a
left turn if you don't want to follow
that that's how you know
that's Oblivion Skyrim right so you can
you don't have to follow that story line
if it's rubbing you the wrong way I like
that having the option you know here
says Starfield doesn't even push the
progressive boat all that much from what
I can tell most of its companions abide
by the sexuality of the player when it
comes to romance while going with the
non-binary gender option will also lock
you to a specific protagonist voice that
can't be changed no matter how you might
sound or look in reality which brings me
to the next story which is um balers
gate which I also uh I just started
playing balers gate um and and this was
silly and I almost just couldn't do it
sorry whatever I'm 37 the wokeness in
this game was beyond was was almost just
I just I just okay look usually when I
play these games I just do like random
character I don't care and the name will
be like random letters whatever dude
it's a first- person game you know
you're sneaking around with uh balers
gate it's a more of like an overhead uh
turn-based
RPG but with balers gate you can be when
you're creating you create two
characters to start with and uh you
create one more directly and then one as
a companion and so I'm like okay you
know balder's gay I like Ian tried
playing it I'll play this one and so in
the character creation you can choose
body type one two three or four I think
there's four body types there's
basically thin woman man fat woman and
fat man or like widebody I guess then
there's gender identity and voice so you
can have like a type one body which is
female with a dude's face and and like a
female voice like you know I don't know
or or you can have like a a woman with
like a dude Voice who identifies as a
man identity is actually a character
characteristic in the game so you can
take a female totally female character
in every possible way and then say
identifies as a man and I've I just I
I'm like what is the purpose of this so
here's what ends up happening I always
just do like random character creation
like yeah I don't care now balers gate
is like d andd so there a lot more
complicated choices you have to make but
let me just tell you something funny
happens in the woke future of video
gaming let me
explain when you play Fallout 3 and you
you are you can choose your character
male or female if you choose male and
then click randomize it will choose a
random haircut with random facial
features and make a random looking guy
if you choose female you can do the same
thing random looking women with random
looking hair like the hair could be long
could be short could be spiky whatever
you could have scars you could have
tattoos but when you mix it all together
and I pressed randomized the first thing
I got was a purple
haired man big masculine in man face
with a female purple haircut bright
pinkish purple with big boobs who talk
like a dude and then I was just like if
the character can be male and female at
the same time random typically gives you
something that
is
particularly what's the what's the right
word egregious no no no like atypical
not normal like if you chose guy and
then randomized a guy in any other video
game you'll get some like random guy and
it'll be like hi I'm a guy you pick home
and you're like woman but with balers
gate it's like every character was some
weird amalgam of male and female yeah I
couldn't get my guy to stop looking like
a woman it was really frustrating and
there's like I press randomize one and
it's like a a dude's buzz cut with a
female face and a super ripped man body
but talking like this like a woman and
I'm like identifying as a as a woman but
looking like a big ripped guy or like
the fat woman body with a big bearded
dude's face talking like this I'm like
it's just you know look it's one thing
to make a character based on you but the
issue is when they mix it all together
and then when I was creating the next
character who apparently is like a main
character or something similar it's it's
it's similar it's just like random
features that don't mix and it's I don't
know it's just crazy it's just pure
chaos I kept hit other than that the
game's fine I actually enjoy the
mechanics I wanted to spend no time on
character creation so I kept hitting
random and it kept giving me these like
these BL I don't Blasphemous is the
right word but these like things that
were like abhorent to react to Nature
they were like
and I just kept hitting random until a
normal person appeared and I took the
first one I saw good enough I was just
I'm like I don't understand what I'm
supposed to do with this maybe it's just
like uh it's supposed to emulate what
game devs look like they're like they're
building it off themselves people have
pointed that out that characters in
movies tend to look like the writers of
these movies or the graphic designers
like seriously there's like a meme about
it where it's like there's a woman and
she's and she's got like frizzy hair and
glasses and she's like I made a game and
the character is literally her and it's
like okay but this one I I I agree with
you Abomination might be the word yeah
hideous the physical characteristics
that you get don't affect the
characters's ability right so if you're
if it looks really ripped it's not more
strong than if it's not they kind of
about the same in some game games it
matters because of hit boxes like uh how
big your character is determines if
someone is like attacking you but not
not this game this game is like a
turn-based RPG with a bunch of different
stats I the game's actually really fun
um it's kind of like I don't know I'm
I'm only like an hour in and it's a bit
nonsensical like random things are just
happening but but I'm having fun with it
and it's a cool mechanics and I like the
RPG style it's DN it's basically D and
but it I almost turned it off right away
when I'm playing this game and it's just
like there I don't I don't understand
the purpose of identity in the game like
seriously the character doesn't seem to
be influenced or anything by this but
there was a funny meme which uh actually
got me you know I start I I found after
I start seeing all stuff where a guy is
complaining that he bought the game but
all of the dude characters keep trying
to bang his dude he's like my character
is just like a a ranger guy and all of
the companions keep trying to have sex
with me like what is going on why are
they all gay and that that was really
interesting to me in this in this
concept of where woke gaming goes in
most games there was the protagonist his
allies and then maybe his love interest
maybe but now because these games are
becoming more open world and they want
to entertain all identities every
interaction has to have a component of
some sexual or romantic Endeavor whereas
games did not used to have that they
would have like love interest that you
could maybe now it's just like you've
made a guy character well all the guys
are gay and they they want to do you do
you want that in your video games like
is that do you want feel like if want
exactly I feel like if you wanted to it
to be like who are you in love with
you'd play like Sims 2 or whatever you
wouldn't play this game seems strange to
me that's been my biggest issue with
this I could really care less it's just
like tell me a good story I want to play
a good video game to learn a good story
not spend 15 minutes in character
creation like I just feel like they're
hiring these teams to focus on loving
interests and purple hair when it's like
yo like Tim said I want to just fight
the dragon man every like seriously give
it a try if you have the game anybody
who has the game probably experiened
already but if you haven't I I'm not
suggesting you buy it just for this I'm
having fun with the game so far it's
like it's it's pretty fun so it's it's a
tad complicated in a lot of ways but
it's worth it but just go to the
character creation hit random and you're
going to go if it's anything like
Divinity 2 there's a lot of combinations
so like one guy can squirt oil on the
ground and the other guy can shoot fire
at it and make it expl
yes I I believe you can do that that's
what the game's all about for me not who
is the character going to have sex with
and it's it's rough for kids like if you
want to let your 12-year-old play a game
you keep in mind there's nudity in that
game that you can turn on and off and it
the first thing it asked me when you
turn the game on I was like do you want
nudity yes or no yes and yes is the
default I said yes I'll say do not give
your kids this game it's like real life
Sodom and gomorra mhm yeah look the
game's fine uh like the game play is
pretty great I'm enjoying it it's a it's
a lot of fun
uh you like roll a D20 and see I I have
some critical successes that are really
fun but uh I would not give uh anyone
like any any child in my family my
future child or like my you know my
nephews or nieces or whatever I wouldn't
give this game because they're going to
be confused by why the character like
the character creation stuff pronouns
identity and all that stuff that's Creo
indoctrination and so that story about
Starfield is interesting they're like
it's not even that woke it's just in the
future they respect pronouns bro
pronouns are cult garbage nonsense
not even every language has pronouns
that's the crazy thing it is your weirdo
Americanized white liberal cult that's
not what the future is sorry have a nice
day yeah from what I've seen with
Starfield like I'm trying to play
devil's advocate here because it to me
it's only that was only a tiny component
component was the pronouns to me they
gave that project to a small team or one
or two employees and said have fun I
think it's a two-edged sword for that
same reason I think the game's so great
I think they've had a lot of people just
be able to create their own stories and
like story lines that you can play
through in the game so you're going to
get some weird stuff but you're also
going to get some really unique gems in
my opinion do you think it's better than
Fallout 4 no no uh I
don't I don't think it's better than
Fallout um are you a video game guy it's
still good I like it though no but um I
you know I think whoever made this game
you know Russia and China never would
allow anything like this within like a
thousand miles of their border and I
think in America we have a really big
problem with this sort of stuff in ating
the youth confusing them like Tim said
at a young age about all these these
things that they shouldn't be thinking
about they should be when I played video
games when I was younger it was like we
Sports you know it was just dumb stuff
like that now you got all this I mean
there is a vested interest that is
pushing this trying to push people down
this path and that path ultimately is
about not having babies and doing
freakish stuff yeah like Mario would
save the princess you'd be like I saved
the girl there my my male like my
ancestral DNA is lit on fire cuz I saved
the princess but now it's like Mario
walking in with his shirt he's kind of
sweaty and like I don't want to see him
pushing the princess up against the wall
and like them making out like you don't
need to add that stuff to Super Mario
Brothers and a lot of these new games
are like they're going so cinematic but
like to a fault I mean I don't know I
mean I guess how many how many of these
games or shows really need that
component in it I don't think you need
it at all but I'm from an era where they
didn't have it so well and I think it's
because some people are just more they
expect sexually explicit content more
casually all the time now and I would
blame that on pornography and the
readily available access that I mean
people are like it's not compelling
unless you see this but actually you
guys are Testament as the fact that like
video games were compelling when they
had strong story lines they're for sure
moving us to a game that's a movie that
is a porn where you are the main
character in VR where you have an open
world with abilities and but you can
also have sex like that's where we're
headed it's it's we're heading to a
world which which is going to be open
world VR anything you want at all you're
going to eat ice cream all day you're
going to eat chocolate cake now like for
the time being the VR stuff that exists
there's no point in playing a game where
you eat cake because you don't actually
experience the dopamine hit from eating
the cake but once they get that
neuralink going oh yeah then people are
going to be eating chocolate cake all
day what about drugs if they could if
they could induce like a dopamine
reaction in your brain by taking digital
heroin in the game you're like my
character's going to shoot up jet or
whatever the hell it is jet I think they
make that that's what they do and follow
they breae it in I think that'd be
illegal because it would cause the exact
same problems triggering dopamine
release or whatever would cause the same
artificially or through chemical
induction I think it would just cause
you serious problems they'd have to ban
it but don't know how you do it you're
they're going to go to like neuralink
drug dens where they're like we can
bypass the patch and security features
to trigger whatever feeling you want
yeah cuz at first it'll in the game
you'll be taking the drug and then
you'll be getting the feeling in real
life but then they'll be like no no no
in the game you don't it's illegal to
take the drug in the game they'll be
okay I'm just going to stare at flowers
in the game but you're still going to
get the feeling and then they'll be like
we can't stop cuz basically clicking
like like looking at all your likes on
social media is producing dopamine kind
of like a drug scrolling and scrolling
have you guys watched the peripheral on
Amazon yes
negative and she's got that weird like
it's almost like she's hung over when
she comes out of the uh I forget if it's
a computer game or whatever it is
they're in like a branch timeline but
when she disconnects she's all
disoriented and like weak and everything
so I wonder if we'll get something like
that even if drugs aren't related that
people are just so used to being in the
VR when they come out it's just a total
shock to the system you know guys I I I
have a a confession to make last night I
went to go Liv
Moss I'm proud of you you deserve it and
when I W when I walked in they had big
touchpads and I did not talk to a human
where Taco Bell oh M live M and I got I
got a cheese a crunch and it was
delicious it was worth it have you seen
their but I ordered on the I ordered on
the kiosk and then it just made and
they're like they yell at my initials PE
they got your order right yeah kind of
but I'm just saying like this is like
you're in in the future man I'm talking
like very soon there's not going to be a
counter no you're going to walk in to
the kiosk you're going to hit the
buttons and then you're going to you're
going to it's going to go order 17 and
then you're going to walk over and the
and the it's going to open up and the
food's going to slide out I don't want
some smelly freakish blue haired you
know who knows you know like Starbucks
worker taking my order at 7:00 a.m. when
I'm trying to wake up like just give me
my order put that person to work on an
oil rig or something do something do
something useful you know and if you
can't do that then sucks but we need an
economy that is oriented around human
Prosperity not around like degenerate
freaks expressing their identity handing
me a latte that they didn't even do
anything to I that's to do with AI
takeover oh yeah it does I mean like the
dudes working AI takeover but the people
working there were not like you're
describing it was like a regular dude
and it's just like I don't interact with
him though his labor is better used
elsewhere yeah I think the issue though
is there's a finite amount of better use
elsewhere labor so when we automate away
all the low skill jobs what are you
going to do with all these immigrants
what are you going to do with all these
high school students they're going to be
locked in the noral link pod eating bugs
and they going to be like life is good I
think the answer to that is I think the
answer to that is a having a shorter
work week I mean you don't you don't
really need people working 40 or 80
hours a week as so many are uh to make
this country run you could have way more
free time for the average American that
American that is has that free time I
mean i' I'd hope most people God-fearing
people family oriented people are going
to start new businesses I mean it's
what's happening in China right now
they've got more millionaires than ever
before they got more B milliones than
ever before more people being lifted out
of poverty and their country is not
going down a path of Social degeneracy
and lunacy and Chaos like we are here uh
that's what's happening in America China
is going in a direction of actually
increased prosperity for the average
person despite what you think of the
characteristics of the country itself
and what they value there I've heard
that the way that they responded to co
by shutting down annihilated their
economy is that not
true um I mean their economy did take a
slight hit but you know there's certain
things you talk you can't talk about on
YouTube they viewed Co very differently
than every other country viewed Co we're
going to go to Super Chat so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it Word of Mouth really really does
help and head over to
timcast.net proclivities on the members
only uncensored show so we look forward
to seeing you there plus we're going to
take calls from you our audience and our
members let's read some super chats
crazy Blake says love you guys keep up
the good work rip Roberto Roberto is
still alive it's Roberto Jr I have bad
news Vanessa passed away in her sleep oh
oh my gosh yep yep man so few OG
chickens are remain what is a typical
chicken lifespan 10 years oh wow so
these ones are going quickly but uh I
mean they for a lot of reasons yeah you
know so one had cancer uh the the
chickens that we got we were warned were
a weak batch we got them in the winter
and he was like you know the you're
going to lose some of them CU they're
they're fairly weak you know in the
winter and all that stuff but uh I don't
know Vanessa's been around for almost
three for for she was three yeah and uh
it's unfortunate Roberto Jr we knew had
issues when he would Crow he would
collapse and so we didn't know what to
expect and then he had a heart attack
and died suddenly it's unfortunate very
sad but I think we've only lost maybe
like five out of the massive amount of
chickens that we have so you know and
yeah I how's his air doing we have
Roberto theii and he's got a brother too
so uh they need some names have to
figure it out and Roberto's in there as
well we just you know we don't want him
banging his daughters so he's he's got
to stay separate for the time being
until we get uh until we move some some
everybody around all right zemu says I
like you Jackson but you had one bizarre
take on the Avatar movie also have you
guys seen the first day out Trump rap
song AI is going to make 2024's memee
war Next Level I have not seen it I will
look into
it I started playing Fallout 3 again so
I'm interested in trying Starfield but I
just don't think you could ever beat
Fallout 3 yeah I'm gonna give Starfield
to try I think I mean it' be silly not
to I've been playing Bethesda gam since
the beginning I I like balers gate Baler
Gate's fun they're close by too Ian
Bethesda headquarters Bethesda Maryland
well they're actually not in Bethesda
Maryland but they're right down the road
they're not far I I field trip let's go
Wonder they when when's the new Elder
Scrolls coming out it's going to be a
couple years cuz this one they were
putting everything into in Starfield and
they're doing Fallout 76 and they're
just pushing more of that and it's I
don't know if that game's still getting
updates is might I'm pretty sure they
just put out a new update huh I could be
wrong it's it's decent Fallout 3 is one
of the best games ever made if not the
best video game ever made it's just it's
a masterpiece yeah it's got Liam niss in
it it's got Malcolm McDow in it yeah
where you go you go on like the the old
aircraft carrier days in it Rivet City
she is I didn't know all Zach sure
Felicia days in Fallout wow yeah that
was groundbreaking that game what's your
take on the Avatar movie uh the blue
people were the bad
ones what were their what was their uh
yeah what were they bad about they're
hoarding all the resources these guys
are just trying to come in and make life
a little bit better develop a little bit
real quick no no she's in New Vegas I
was wrong about Fallout 3 anyway
continue they're just the bad people
they there's a this is Wall Street city
of London they're trying to hoard all
the resources from The Working Man
that's trying to get
by huh so if they they don't know they
have the resources that it is it's like
oil that they aren't able to synthesize
yet I think they're living you we we
we've talked about uh I want to do short
films that show the opposite perspective
of like these famous stories in movies
like Star Wars is about a young kid from
a desert Planet who's radicalized by
religious zealots taking a car they
hijack a cargo ship to go blow up a
military base Darth Vader's a war a
disabled War veteran like that's that's
that's the story right there but that's
that's overt like you literally watch
that movie and that's what it is this
kid's like oh wow you're going to fight
the Rebellion they call it against the
empire the death start was called
project Stardust it was a military base
anyway I digress there's a whole bunch
of ways you could interpret other
stories with Avatar I'm like the short
film version from the perspective of the
US or the Earth interests is that they
come to this planet and they see a bunch
of natural resources and the natives are
brutally sacrificing children and
putting on the Altar and fllying them
alive and then they're like do we ignore
this or do we intervene and then you
know on Earth they're like we need to
stop them from sacrificing children and
pulling their hearts out and then the
activists are like you're you're
stealing indigenous culture and one more
thing if you look at the Indian
collective in the United States that's
the organization that's fighting laying
back for all the indigenous tribes
Across America right now H guess who's
the one who's funding it it's Jeff Bezos
Jeff Bezos is funding the Indian
Collective land back for the indigenous
people they just want to protect the
land but there's something more Sinister
at play all right let's read some more
Super
chats what have we where we at Noah sers
says Jackson just want to let you know
there's a fake profile of you going
around following people you follow he I
posted a photo on Ax and tagged you
don't want someone giving you a bad name
you know to be honest though that
happens all the time I get messages from
people who like did you know that
there's
8739 accounts that are imitating you and
I'm like dude whatever like what are you
supposed to do and they're all on
YouTube and they're trying to get people
to download like some crypto app or
something whatever man that's the
conspiracy theory why Elon Musk actually
bought Twitter because people kept
making fake profiles of him and then
doingit Bitcoin scams and he kept
telling them to like stop and then
Twitter was like well whatever so now
he's like everyone's got to be verified
no more of this someone copied my
profile on Instagram earlier this year
and it was like crypto advice and they
messaged my older brother and we like
hello I've gotten interested in the
stock market or like something like that
and you know it was a very close copy
that changed like one letter in my
username but uh I definitely would not
want to be mistaken for a crypto expert
all right Kish aov says Tim you said you
like The Fallout games have you tried
Starfield if not save your time and
money it's absolutely Dreadful oh really
I I need to know why I need to know why
now yeah why you dude okay here's my
theory my theory is that for the last 10
like I said first new IP from Bethesda
in 25 years well you raised a whole
generation on Call of Duty and fortnite
so you have a lot of this rhetoric
online in my opinion is coming from
people who are addicted to multiplayer
games they see the single player how in
depth it is like this is a chore
gratification doesn't exist here see
here here's here's the thing Bethesda
purchased Fallout the IP and then they
took the isometric game applied its lore
which is awesome to their basically like
Elder Scrolls engine I think they bought
it from obsidian right
I think I'm I'm it was obsidian who who
made Fallout yeah and then Fallout New
Vegas which everyone said was way better
was when Obsidian made used their engine
and added the storyline the way they
wanted it Fallout 4 I thought was
Dreadful it's like you no longer had uh
Speech options you had like one of four
buttons to press it just was not
enjoyable and so while I can respect
Elder Scrolls I like Skyrim that's fun
I'm looking forward to the new one I
thought Fallout 76 was kind of bad
they're like there's no people in it
like you're the people I'm like oh yeah
so I am I I am willing to bet I probably
will not like it do they have a good
alchemy crafting system it's yeah it's
very indepth uh bunch of different
crafting stations you can do for
different things um it is like choose
one of four options but once you choose
one option it snakes into like another
three or four so it's not bad and it's a
new game engine that they designed uh I
don't know I just don't want to be
blackpilled on everything I do enjoy it
it's a video game supposed to have fun
let's read some more I mean balers a g
I'm having fun yeah it's it's pretty
it's pretty good uh David says Ian give
us a flex you look like you've made
progress thank you I G I gained about uh
uh 15 lbs wow I clock 152 152 yeah I've
been carrying weights around with me
throughout the day just a couple of 15lb
dumbbells and then this last weekend I
ate for like 48 hours I just kept eating
and eating when I went outside and Ian
sitting on the porch curling and I was
just like I took him with me over he
looked him he was like magga
he's got a magga hat feels so good do
you feel like more energy and everything
yeah immediately the body like um
remembers like this morning I felt all
groggy but I I started doing um just
core exercise and that that soreness
starts off sore and then it starts to
feel really good and then it starts to
wake things up yeah in like six months's
going to be massive he's going to be
like yeah just been been lifting all day
the new liver King
the when we hit the organ meat phase I'm
going to be really uh really interested
to see where we go from there he bring
Luke in he's all about that all right
crazy lemur says Georgia is is blue we
tried to build low-income housing in
Savannah Georgia and they said they
won't approve our project because we are
white the city council is corrupt and we
need an OMG
undercover wh what what's Sheamus doing
down there just draw cartoons like he's
going to contribute to society one of
these days cartoons although I do say uh
I will say his latest cartoon was really
really good I of course was the voice of
fouchy and uh you should really check it
out on Freeds because it's clever
basically Co is a comedian who doesn't
want to be political anymore and
everyone's like huh and they're like
shocked by it and then he basically Co
basically explains you know it was
always like haha that unvaccinated
magacha die that's what he gets but then
when it's a Democrat it's like ha he got
vaccinated you know x amount of times
and then he still gets sick and then
dies or whatever it's never just the
virus that's killing people it's always
some political angle to it and then
fouchi is basically like what what does
he say he's like did you forget who made
you you should you should check it out
it's funny and then he threatens
threatens him there you go all right
let's grab some more Super chats Wilson
Field says Riley Gaines will be speaking
at West Virginia University this
Thursday this uh the event will be
taking place at 700 p.m. at the mountain
lair on campus you do not need to be a
student to attend huh I of course will
be doing timcast IRL on Thursday and I
will be here I wonder if Taylor's going
to be there but uh yeah I don't know
West Virginia where's is is that but
which which Camp is that I think they're
talking about Morgantown morgant Town
yeah yeah okay that's really far away
what is it like three four two and a
half hour three hour drive maybe well a
lot if you're uh if you're watching
maybe you should go cover it I'm sure
there's going to be some type of protest
even at Morgan you know even at
WVU Morgan Town I I'm I'm always CU just
shy three hours yeah I'm always curious
to see what's happening on the college
campuses or at least uh nearby the
college campuses if they're not allowed
on legma says Miss Mr Hinkle I have seen
you described as a Marxist leninist and
Maga communist among other things I have
read your Twitter and it's full of
things suggestive of a rejection of
Classical liberalism I don't however
want to put words in your mouth care to
comment
true to what you want MAA communist both
are do you identify as communist yes
what is the value of
Communism uh orienting government in the
economy for the public
good do yeah but I think I think that's
like uh an
oversimplification well or ideal simply
simply that's what it is I mean I think
uh I think that uh I think that any
communist state that takes for in
America is going to have communist
values or American values rather it's
going to be based on the history of our
country the
Constitution uh I think it would be a
Christian communist state and I think
that we can learn a lot from China and
from the Soviet Union but you look at
China today their their economy is
outpacing ours it's going to it's going
to beat ours totally probably within the
next 5 to 10 years you know Europe is
going down the us is going down China
lifted 845 million people out of poverty
in the last 40 years I think that we
shouldn't be China but I think we can
learn things from China and the Soviet
Union and other countries that have done
it successfully
successfully didn't do it successfully
fell apart they fell apart in 69 years
but what did they do successfully they
took their country from its knees from
dirt from a feudal Society basically to
the economic Powerhouse that defeated
Nazi Germany the bloodiest largest
battle in all of human history yeah but
we're already an economic Powerhouse so
how would benefit us are we an economic
Powerhouse or are we this Byzantine
Labyrinth of insurance companies law
firms that utilizes Wall Street Wall
Street power utilizing the dollar as a
as a tool of financial pressure on the
rest of the world without the dollar
America is not nothing but it's nowhere
near as strong as it is today and when
you see bricks rising up you see Russia
China India South Africa Brazil you see
Saudi Arabia the UAE you see Iran Egypt
seven of the 10 top seven of the top 10
largest oil producing in the Nations
today working to create a new Global
Reserve currency that's going to
challenge the dollar I mean it's not the
end of America but it's not going to be
pretty for us in the future you think
that centrally planning an economy is a
more effective
strategy the priv sector take it I think
that every economy's planned this
economy in the US has planned to enrich
Wall Street Rich Legacy families in our
country it's built to enrich uh you know
the largest Monopoly Capital powers that
reside within the US I think China is a
country that plans the economy to lift
people out of poverty in regions like
Xin Jang and also focuses on giving
people tax relief helping them create
new businesses making sure that they
have enough money to afford homes and
Healthcare and stuff like that I think
America is a country that prioritizes
every single interest of the ruling
class over the interest of the working
man that's why we have 60,000 homeless
veterans 600,000 homeless individuals we
have a higher ratio of homeless in our
country compared to any industrialized
developed Nation on the face of the
Earth what about property rights would
you suggest doing away with them I think
that we should I think we should just
just give property to the people Trump's
talking about this new plan for America
cities he's talking about 10 new cities
across the United States we'd have uh to
you know top Elite architect uh
architecture Specialists throughout the
country that submit plans to build new
cities where people Young Americans with
families are basically going to get the
opportunity to buy land buy homes for
pennies on the dollar for super cheap
and I think we should we should do that
right now I mean why why is it that
every American is governed by debt every
American is in debt when it comes to
their home loans every American's in
debt when it comes to student loans uh
even medical debt is is insane right now
in the United States uh why why is it
this is the last thing I'll say
everything about communism is about
taking power away from the wealthy
hordes the the sackers the Rockefellers
uh the bushes all these families that
are hoarding our wealth our resources in
America right now and keeping it for
themselves for who knows knows what why
is it that Bill Gates and Jeff Bezos are
allowed to buy up all the land in this
country and no one questions that but
the idea of giving every American enough
land to get by maybe have a small garden
or a farm or something like that that's
insane and no one's allowed to talk
about that and that's some communist
conspiracy that no one's ever going to
imagine ever taking shape here well
compromise all of the land seized by the
Bureau of Land Management we uh break it
apart and we give pieces of it to uh
various American citizens I was going to
say this doesn't really sound like
communism it almost sounds like just a
form of Socialism that you're describing
that you want the government to do more
for the American people cuz communism
would be the government owns all the
land we're not getting it yeah so well
that's not the case in China China
they've given land to the people and but
what I think you can say they're a weird
kind of like
postcommunist like authoritative State
it's like land leases right yeah well uh
China is 100% ml line I mean you look at
Ma you look at D Xiao ping you look at
uh xiin ping I mean you read his his uh
his books governance of China it's all
an ml line it's 100% Marxist leninist
and there's a lot of people who try to
say well China's like semi capitalist
it's a capitalist communist state it's
because they don't want to admit that
communism is actually winning whereas
pure capitalism here or corporate
capitalism whatever you want to call it
is failing beyond belief and the last
thing I'll say is about government
takeover I think there should be
government takeover uh like what Russia
is doing Russia has gas prom they're
utilizing the interests of the of the
country oil natural gas to benefit the
public I mean uh you look at some of the
finest infrastructure that's been built
in Russia it's happening because the
revenue generated by their their uh you
know their utilities we have utilities
here that are only enriching these
shareholders of these massive
corporations that do nothing in the
interest of the Working Man and they
actually indebt many Americans based
upon how expensive basic utilities are
huh let's read some more Super chats
Heron gaming news says Tim how much
closer do you think we are to seeing
people who voted for Trump being
arrested um I don't know several weeks
passed I mean two and a half years
passed how many people got arrested for
being at the capital on January 6 but
didn't actually go in the building who
how many people were just there at the
rally walked up the steps confused
didn't know what's going on and are
being criminally charged I think that
qualifies for people who just voted for
Trump we're not talking about someone
who smashed a window and fought cops
yeah I understand charges for those
people maybe two decades a little bit
extreme but there are a lot of people
who are like walking around confused
bumbling about and they got criminally
charged and they got two even just two
months is insane for someone who had no
idea what was going on so yeah that I
think is already
happening all right Matt's magic and P
says can I come on and play Tim in MTG
depends we can play uh multiplayer
Commander like what do you think is good
four players yeah four is good for
Commander and um maybe once we finally
get the uh Club up and running which is
just everything just takes a million
years because my job day to-day is like
doing this and then everyone else is
doing everything else so it's like if I
want want to open a club where we can
play cards and hang out that's on the
back burner everybody's doing their
specific job and then like first thing
that happens to the coffee shop it's
getting delayed because we have to do
Remodeling and there's permits and
Historic Society once that's up and
running then we move to second floor
then we got install like handicap stuff
once that's done we do third floor so
it'll be really cool to have like a a I
what would you call like a hobby shop
we're going to have probably trading
cards um we'll we'll see if we get poker
legalized got some really awesome stuff
happening in on that front we got to
figure out how to do poker properly I
don't think I I don't know what the
argument is to have it complet to have
it regulated at all why shouldn't it
just be if you want to play a game where
you can put chips on the table you can I
don't understand what the point of of
any kind of regulation on it is but
we'll see what happens I'm talking with
the government about how we move forward
with that but then we're going to have a
skate shop and it's going to be a place
you go to you know hang out watch movies
and and engage in fun hobbies play music
maybe it'll be it'll be it'll be read
and then yes we will have uh
commander and we'll have prizes really
awesome
prizes we'll grab some more Super chats
Raymond g Staley JR says Tim did you see
Biden walk out of the Medal of Honor
ceremony it's becoming common place for
politicians to disrespect the nation
they presentent everyone please run for
any and all local offices local offices
are where it's at that's what you need
to win mhm yep mhm what do we got Jason
Hutchinson says it's not stealing land
you can never own what you can't
defend yeah I think when you look at the
arguments if you look at movies like
Harry Potter and we're talking about
doing these you know alternate views
Harry Potter Voldemort is a
one-dimensional villain they never quite
explain he's just a supremacist who is
evil for no reason he's just just like
an arrogant creepy guy it's like okay
well give him like a tragic backstory
sort of he was an orphan and he was a
sociopath mhm and his mom like con
someone into fall in love with her so
he's from this like terrible family but
there's there's there's there's no
logical Rhyme or Reason described as to
what he's doing and why other than he's
just a supremacist but that is horribly
one-dimensional look at look at look at
modern reality and actually look to a
white supremacist they will tell you a
whole bunch of stuff about why they
believe what they believe they should
have gone to that with Voldemort
JK rling should have had voldermort and
like the death theaters explain exactly
what it is they don't like about people
of you know mixed Wizarding families or
whatever instead it was very very
onedimensional
imagine if imagine Harry Potter from the
perspective of the right we know the
left says everyone's a Nazi everyone's a
supremacist imagine what Harry Potter
would look like if you inverted it based
on the culture War today Voldemort is
actually just like we shouldn't be
allowing people you know through our
borders when you know we can't maintain
this economic Ally things like that it
would be it would be about National
sovereignty and it would be about
economics and it would be about fighting
for the people of his country it's not
about whether or not you have magic or
don't it's about are you paying taxes to
this government blah blah blah blah blah
Wizarding taxes and those that marry the
the non- Wizards don't have to pay or
but like it's fine that Voldemort it's a
supremacist you can totally go with that
line he's basically magic Hitler but
just they should have like she she
needed to elaborate on like what it is
they really wanted and it was you know
overly simplistic not to mention the the
great Wizarding War it was a civil war
it was not it was it was it it was kind
of like a political Uprising within
their country we know that in Harry
Potter's Universe there's a bunch of
other countries of different schools
they weren't fighting the war so come on
do better anyway what were we talking
about Harry Potter or something all
right because the reason I brought that
up is we're talking about Avatar and and
what land you could you could own or
whatever all right everybody uh let's
see Austin Fairbank says says Tim since
you're so obsessed with the modern day
American Civil War you should give the
darkest path book by Jeff hirs a read or
listen it has an interesting take on
everything on a very possible future
right on if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.net the show at timcast IRL you
can follow me at timcast basically
everywhere Jackson do you want to shout
anything out the dive with Jackson
Hinkle on YouTube and any Twitter or
anything else you want to shout out well
Twitter Elon doesn't like me he's so I'm
not shouting that out fine fair enough
uh I'm Hannah CL brimo I'm a writer for
timcast.net and on Instagram we have a
lot of great work from all our
journalists if you want to follow me
personally I'm uh Hannah cler upy on
Instagram I'm HC brimo on on Twitter and
I just did uh Sheamus cogins podcast
today called shamer so you should
definitely check that out he's the worst
but uh you get to see me break off to
cover some breaking news so he is the
worst he is the worst I'm glad he's gone
saddle bags worst worst Sheamus uh hey
goodbye everyone Ian Crossland follow me
on the internet at Ian Crossland and
Jackson cool talking to you man
especially uh we barely got into the
Communist stuff I I like talking to
people with different political
ideologies I don't know a lot of people
that self-identifies communist I like
talking especially with you guys cuz
usually people just soy out but like you
know Tim's like well compromise let's do
this it make makes and with the the
Twitter nationalization conversation too
yeah like we have to we have to work
through the logic of what the idea is
not just yeah cuz I I thought as you
were talking like oh I see the goal that
you're looking at I I have a similar
goal that I'm aiming at and the
methodologies that we use may could be
end up being I think people he the label
and they freak out they don't ask the
questions well maybe that we go deeper
into it in future date good conversation
man maybe do a culture war and get a
bunch of different politics involved see
you later you took the words right out
of my mouth Ian maybe we can get like
philon on here next time because he's
like the libertarian guy around here
it'd be really interesting to have that
hear that conversation you guys can
follow me at Kellen PDL I'm mainly
active on X uh but yeah follow me there
thanks guys we will see all of you over
at
timcast.net
that